so last night we have this uh viral clip
going around where the president of
Ukraine said that the U.S will have to
set its children to fight and die just
like they do and of course the fact that
Checkers Rush In And like no no he's not
saying that we're going to send U.S
troops on the ground in Ukraine first
because there's already Special Forces
operating there but he's saying no no no
just when the U.S is dragged into World
War III because of Ukraine then the
American children Must Die okay all
right well let's talk about it I'll show
you the fact Checkers and it's really
funny and then I think one of the most
interesting stories that I've seen in a
long time is the mayoral election in
Chicago with Lori Lightfoot The woke
Democrat losing
and what I find fascinating is that I
don't think she lost due to policy I
don't think she technically lost due to
Crime I think crime was a factor because
it motivated people to vote but if you
take the electoral map showing what
neighborhoods voted for which candidate
and overlay it over a racial demographic
map hey it's nearly one for one the
white neighborhoods voted for the white
guy the black neighborhoods voted for
the black guy and the black lady and the
Latino neighborhoods voted for the
Latino guy except for one neighborhood
it's the college neighborhoods they
voted for a different black guy but uh
it's interesting to see that it seems
after all is said and done race was a
bigger component than policy itself but
we'll talk about all that stuff before
we get started head over to timcast.com
become a member by clicking that join us
button at timcast.com and you'll get
access to our uncensored members only
live show Monday through Thursday at 11
PM and we are working on the Discord
server
should be coming soon and then you'll be
able to sign up chat 24 7 you know with
other members of the uh of the website
and then during the live uncensored show
some people will even be able to call in
obviously we can't have every single
person call in but we'll try and do some
uh select call-ins for the members only
show and uh as a member you are keeping
this operation going that's how we do it
our our customers are not the
advertisers we do sell ads sometimes our
customers are you guys so that means if
you like what you see and you want it to
continue becoming a member is how you do
it if at any point ever everybody was
like no we're not willing to pay for
this then I probably wouldn't pick up
advertisers and that'd be that'd be it
you guys are what make it work and as
members you're also making sure we don't
have to worry about censorship or
corporations coming to us and being like
hey we don't want you talking about this
and that's the the traditional media
model big companies get big contracts
for advertising and then when the
company says hey there's a negative
story in the Press don't talk about it
they go you got it boss we're not going
to do that with your support we won't
have to so smash that that like button
subscribe to this channel share the show
with your friends joining us tonight to
talk about all of this and more is Julie
Kelly
hello who are you what do you do who am
I good question
um Julie Kelly I am a writer for
American greatness and greatness.com
and I've written two books working on my
third but my last book when I was here
last year to talk to you was about
January 6 how the Democrats have turned
the capital protest into a war on terror
against the political right
thanks for having me absolutely there's
a lot of new developments there with the
footage that's coming out so we'll talk
about all that thanks for coming should
be fun we got Phil Labonte hanging out
hello I am Phil Labonte uh lead vocalist
for All That Remains anti-communist and
counter-revolutionary
hi everyone Ian Crossland here happy to
be here Julie I'll probably ask you
what's the name of the book The January
6th book you did January 6th how
Democrats used the capital protest to
launch a war on terror against the
political right all right I think I said
it wrong the first time that's what
happens when you have a long subtitle
yeah pressing the buttons what's up dude
yo what's up guys at surge.com hopefully
uh the mixer is dialed in today we'll
see and I just want to say real quick
because someone asked will I be able to
chat with Ian on Discord yes I was just
thinking Matt that I would go in there
and type
that's right Ian will be sitting there
and then you can fill his mind with no
like show up to this show and his hair
will be all messed up and he's like the
things they were telling me I was in
I could go everyone's gonna type
everyone's gonna try and argue with you
about like the thing to say on the show
it's gonna be can you make videos and
post videos in Discord like is uh yeah
guys yeah I'm pretty sure pretty sure we
could make like a video room or
something but then you know whenever
someone gets mad at your opinions they
just gotta pay to be a member so they
can tell you in the Discord you know and
it actually changes me keep that in mind
all right everybody let's jump into this
first story so we have this tweet from
at remarks on twitter Justin this is
from yesterday night around 6 23 P.M
Ukraine Ukraine's President zielinski
says U.S will have to send their sons
and daughters the same way we are
sending our sons and daughters to War
what I love about this is yes he said it
yes it's confirmed but of course they're
panicking and they're uh look at this
fact check from AP News
zelenski didn't say here's what AP says
zelenski didn't say U.S troops needed to
fight in Ukraine that's weird that's
actually what he did say he did say that
so here's here's the framing they're
going with
claim a video clip shows Ukrainian
President Vladimir zielinski saying that
Americans will have to send their sons
and daughters to the war in Ukraine ap's
assessment missing context zelenski was
explaining that if Russia attacked NATO
member states which are U.S allies the
U.S would likely send troops to protect
those countries he was not suggesting
Americans would have to fight in Ukraine
right because it's going to be in Poland
that the U.S troops are in Poland and
they'll never go into Ukraine there will
be no advancement on that front once the
U.S pushes Russia out of Poland and then
Russia is occupying Ukraine the U.S of
course would respect we are done
supporting this war Ukraine has lost of
course because because that's what he
certainly meant they say the clip cut
from a two-hour live stream news
conference on the somber one-year
anniversary of Russia's somber come on
guys show zelenski speaking with the
audio dubbed by a translator quote
the U.S will have to send their sons and
daughters exactly the same way as we are
sending their sons and daughters to war
our sons what no he said they are sons
and diets very weird quote right and
they will have to fight because it's
NATO that that we're talking about and
they will be dying God forbid because
it's a horrible thing
so what he's basically saying is with
the fact check in mind when the U.S is
dragged into World War III over their
country that's not a NATO Ally then
we'll have to send our children to die
in Europe oh okay why why on Earth would
we send people to defend Europe if it's
going to be a nuclear war if it's the
U.S versus Russia we can die in the U.S
just as easily as we can you know died
in nuclear fire in the U.S as easily as
we could die in a nuclear fire in the uh
in Europe I think there's no reason for
the for the U.S to send people to Europe
in a nuclear war I'm not even convinced
necessarily it'll be nuclear I think the
moment we send troops to Europe a whole
bunch of oil refinery just explode all
at once
there's gonna be cyber attacks power
plants will shut down the grid will go
on go out I I I would imagine
that when it comes to cyber War it's a
Mexican standoff and every country has
their finger on the button to destroy
another country's infrastructure the
crazy thing is that when we started
developing the internet and then we
hooked everything into it without the
thought of security we basically built
towers of of sticks of bamboo and we're
we built our cities on top of bamboo and
it's like you know it's holding us up
like Bamboo's not it's pretty great you
can make scaffolding out of it but it's
really easy to knock down because it's
not that strong and every country is
built on top of it so you don't need a
nuke they can just type in some press
enter and whoosh
I think internet goes out I think well I
mean I I think that that you're probably
right and I think that that only adds to
my point that there there is no longer
the fight over Lane over European land
the way that uh the way that zielinski's
framing it if you are talking about a
you know fifth generational Warfare or
whatever
fifth generational
like psychological operations and stuff
well I uh yeah that I think that's the
kind of stuff that would be used
especially if you're talking about you
know all-out War if you're talking about
nuclear war as well there's I just don't
see Americans needing to hold European
uh land you know I don't see Americans
need to to go into Europe in in a you
know type of War you know you know you
know what got me really on board with
voting for Trump this next time around
is that video from uh the whatever
podcast I don't know if you all have
seen those clips that are going viral
where he gets these low-wit narcissistic
women to talk about their views on
things and I'm just watching the the
clip of that woman talk about feminism
and why she's a feminist and her
inability to articulate any kind of
coherent thought
and then I just thought about it and I
was like
is this why we have the Petro dollar
is this is this why we have the Federal
Reserve are we bombing kids in in Yemen
and Syria and other countries so that
these vapid narcissistic women can have
cheap products to smear on their faces
you know I'm ready to go back and work
the farm I'm I'm ready to just get back
to chopping wood and working really hard
and and these luxuries are bad for us
the U.S I understand the fear I guess is
probably that China would start crushing
the world with with you know their
ridiculous weird communism and that's
probably that literally is a bad thing
so okay fine that's a tough question
right there but if is is this why the
U.S does these things like is the reason
we're fighting in Ukraine for the
expansion of energy so that these vapid
narcissistic entitled Millennials and
gen's ears can be as dumb as a box of
rocks but get free stuff the reason I'm
like vote for Trump close borders build
the factories everybody's to get back to
work we're not doing this anymore you're
not getting a free ride the reason I'm
not absolutely out of my mind enraged
about the slavery in China or in
wherever wherever they have I mean
slavery you know Loosely but where
they're building these these these
phones is because I'm getting I'm I'm
Sedated by the technology because I have
access to cheap computers and phones if
I didn't if I wasn't seeing value from
the slavery I'd be out of my mind about
it but instead I'm like you're there's a
lost analysis there's also the fact that
that you know there's enough
horrible things that happen every single
day to drive uh someone insane if they
knew about them all like the world is a
big place and there's a lot of people
and there's a lot of suffering so the
the fact that that there's you know
terrible things going on in China and
stuff if you don't have the capacity to
know about it and you you shouldn't
focus on it and that's one of the
reasons why I think that people are so
frequently depressed is Because the
Internet is delivered delivering bad
news right to their news feed all day
long and they doom scroll and stuff I
think that has a psychological effect on
people I think what preceded his comment
here was he was asked about polling in
the United States where the opposition
to the war in Ukraine is increasing and
he was asked about Republican lawmakers
say people like MTG Etc who are want
accountability at the very least for
what 120 billion that's going there
so they kind of teed him up for this so
this was part of his rant basically
saying that Republican that Americans
shouldn't have a contrary opinion about
the war that elected officials should
support it a hundred percent and if they
don't this is where this is going what's
interesting is you didn't hear anyone
from the regime say oh no no this is not
where that's headed because this is the
natural escalation you know we've seen
this before so we keep sending more
artillery we're sending Jets who's
teaching Ukrainian Pilots how to use our
Weaponry we're just just send it with
some instructions I mean this is where
it's headed
so you haven't seen anyone from the
defense department or anyone with the
Biden White House say no that this is
that was totally out of line that's not
going to be the case is this where this
is probably where it's headed I know
that we got a long way to go but I'm
curious your thoughts on what would
happen the day Donald Trump takes office
again with the Ukraine war still in
action do you think he just pulls
everything back like a snap of a finger
you know Tim I think that the more this
goes on and the more it does escalate it
increases Trump's chances of winning I
mean I think this issue alone
could be a winning issue for him
um that and the Border because it's not
going to change but this at where how
this is going directionally this could
be his biggest issue so yes he would
take over I think he learned his lessons
about who he can and can't trust in the
military industrial complex and the
Pentagon which is basically no one
um and so I think if he becomes
president he fires Mark milley and a
whole lot of other people and he
automatically says I'm not listening to
any advice we're done with this I can
already see the political ads that are
going to be running on this channel and
every other YouTube channel it's going
to be a red screen and it's going to
show a trained derailment and there's
going to be some some like somber deep
voice of a 50 year old man who sounds
like he smoked a pack of cigarettes
every day you know since he was 12
saying something like when a trained
derailment spread toxic chemicals
killing livestock and threatening the
lives of millions Joe Biden flew to
Ukraine and then it's going to be like
spending 100 billion dollars of your
money on a country for what reason don't
vote for Joe Biden
probably that day alone could be the
that was it for me at least I agree and
even even you know look I like DeSantis
but even that day was big on like
DeSantis went out of my mind on that one
that's right Donald Trump going down
there giving out Big Macs was just like
I was laughing and it felt good like it
felt humanly good that Donald Trump was
there with a with a smile buying Big
Macs it's like almost stupid but it was
it was human it was something and and
the funny thing is like let me just let
me just say like this Donald Trump went
to East Palestine Biden went to Ukraine
holy are you serious right man look I
mean we don't even know if this guy is
going to be able to run anyway so maybe
that's it maybe they're just like who
cares yeah it's not going to be him
right
but I think that was his man you know
that's Trump's magic and I mean I I I'm
a DeSantis fan too we spent a lot of
time in Florida
um he just does not have that sort of
personal connection uh that Trump has
honed over years that that comes by him
naturally and that was on display uh in
Ohio uh despite the contrast you know
even if even if Biden uh hadn't uh made
his trip to Ukraine it on its own it
reminds people of what makes made Trump
a special uh president it was a surprise
yeah Biden's like surprise everybody hey
I went to Ukraine and we're like why
walk this line that's amazing to give
him 500 million dollars yeah I remember
500 million to a half a half a billion
dollars
some uh Military Support wow then Janet
Yellen went so but yeah so I'm watching
those videos of these vapid young people
and I'm just thinking about what is this
system that we live in and why do we do
it it's not oh sorry well no it's just
like we want to maintain the Petro
dollar the United States manufactures
nothing so in order to maintain our GDP
we for one we do produce culture and
spread those movies and music around and
make money off that so there is an
export there but for the most part we
don't manufacture and Export things so
the only reason our economy is propped
up is because we are it's it's a mostly
unipolar world not becoming multi-polar
but that means the United States
controlled everything decimated its
competition and put guns everywhere and
so it's like use the US dollar to buy
oil or else which means when this
country wants to buy oil they need to
buy the dollars from us and we can
charge whatever we want because we got
the guns and then for us we need to
print the dollars and buy the oil how
about that it's sort of like having I've
never had uh like a grandfather that's
super rich he's like the patriarch of
the family and everyone hates him in the
family but he's the one with all the
money why does everyone hate him in just
such a dick he's such an alcoholic
abusive racist old from way back and
that's what the United States has become
this hated patriarchy it's the Vestige
of the military industrial we used to be
so great in the 80s and 70s so great you
know because we were actually pretty
hated back then too yeah but we did
prevent world war three before the
invasion
they really hated the Iran Contra thing
was insane
so and you know John Rockefeller he was
probably always I don't know I don't
know if he's personally a jerk but I
think you know you get these weird old
Patriarchs that are like they control
all the money in the family and I feel
like that's how people are just waiting
for the United States to die because you
can't kill the old man that's why I'm
saying you vote for Trump he builds a
wall he brings the factories back he
stops the foreign policy garbage and
that means we're not going to be the
global police or anything like that and
that means all of these vapid young
people have to roll up their sleeves and
learn how to chop wood and I'm I'm
totally fine with that yeah I don't I
think it's good that's it the gluttony
of this country is a huge problem just
there's tons of really dumb people who
don't work and the reason why we're
seeing people getting degrees in like
feminist dance theory is because you
don't have to do anything it's like you
used to have to break rocks I'm going to
be an influencer yeah that's right when
China asked there was that study that's
they asked Chinese kids you know what do
you want to be when you grow up they're
like astronauts and they asked American
kids in YouTubers or whatever
they wanted to be personalities I think
it's not the luxury that's destroying
people or the even the excessive luxury
it's the lack of uh relativism to the
luxury if you're born in luxury you
don't know it's a luxury you got to get
out of the system go to South America
and spend some time in the jungle where
if you eat the fruit you're going to get
dysentery and then come back to the
United States and realize that running
water is a godsend I don't think the
fruit gives you dysentery you should
check it out go to bailin it's where
they poop in the river they don't know
that's that's the water not the fruit it
gets into the ground into the into the
soil and then if you eat the fruit that
comes out of it there's parasites and
stuff in it and also it's a different
biome like your body can't handle
certain chemicals the way they can here
um I got real sick eating acai in Brazil
yeah I ate a fruit that's crazy it was
like sweet creamy fruit I'd never eaten
before and I just started puking
immediately after I ate it it was crazy
but it tasted so good oh really yeah it
was wild let me pull up this story from
Reuters here's the good news everybody
from Reuters EU aims to team up with
defense industry to speed up ammunition
output oh that's good news I mean I
personally don't mind it it's I'm having
a hard time finding gold.556 so are you
okay if you're upsets produce something
you can import you know the European
Union aims to join forces with the
blocks defense industry to speed up and
scale up the production of ammunition
badly needed in the battlefield in
Ukraine and to replenish military stocks
at home its Chief said on Saturday make
no mistake ladies and gentlemen this is
world war three will it escalate to the
point out will escalate to a conflict
outside of Ukraine is the question but
NATO and Russia are fighting and other
countries I believe are soon to be
involved China may start even
zielinski's warning about this China
could team up with Russia and then it's
World War III it's like oh okay if China
does they're not going to say that's the
start of World War III they're going to
say the Ukrainian invasion was the start
of World War II they're going to argue
that the Euro my Dan protest was the
start of World War III so we're in the
forest right now man I'll just say this
seeing a story this is like people were
showing it around like crazy actually
from a week ago seeing a story where
Europe is going to start Mass producing
bullets I'm like yeah they're getting
ready for war we're going to see other
manufacturing too and we're going to see
the U.S shipping more more of this stuff
in so short-term good news if you invest
in like uh Lockheed or Northrop Grumman
you're probably actually I'm gonna check
that right now it's a it I mean this is
this is a an evergreen statement but
it's it's a good idea if you're a
Firearms owner to make sure that you
have you know a sufficient amount of
ammunition for each of your Firearms so
if you've got multiple firearms in
multiple different calibers you need to
get some ammunition for all the calibers
lockheed's up nine percent over last
year there you go that's a little bit
above you know average that's
outperforming the market too right right
markets down you know but nine percent
all right what do we got like Northrop
how are they doing is that publicly
traded oh yeah sure
there we go Northrop Grumman how are
they doing uh let's see in the past year
they're up four percent so big spike
they were actually they actually dropped
down quite a bit but uh you know it
really does seem like what's another
weapons manufacturer Boeing's up four
percent they dropped down what happens
you see the spikes and the drops and I
think what happens is these well Boeing
uh 0.65 of the past year l310 I'm
getting four percent over the past year
that's where 240 per per share yeah yeah
weird look look at L3 Technologies down
43 over the past five years L3 what's L3
L3 they make a lot of laser devices and
smaller lasers they're doing really well
or what there's no they're way down
there they're down 17 oh no yeah you
know we don't we don't need lasers but
you see the spikes and the drops they'll
sell off and then buy back up and do
these organized I mean it's illegal to
do that but I think that's what happens
is they sell off stock plummets people
panic sell and then they buy a bunch
back up unfortunate but that's what
happens when people control the market
my graphene Investments doing real well
yeah man wow
I'm just waiting for the moment that
like these weapons manufacturers come
out and they're like we've made a
tremendous Discovery in weapons
technology the graphene bomb and then
it's just like the stock jumps making
better primer a couple nights ago and uh
just yeah graphene's gonna be I'm going
to utilize graphing bullets graphene
rifling all that stuff it's just
I'm not convinced but sure but think
about those corporations there's no war
okay we're out of the Middle East the
war nobody really believes in war and
Terror there's nothing really looming
what happens to those corporate I mean
these are made these are huge they're
still making interesting products so
they're a huge military you've got so
many people invested in foreign war in
the military but there's nowhere to go
so what do you do will you get a clown
like zielinski and you pump him up as
some sort of Savior and you let this you
know
for years Putin obviously is a bad guy
but he's not the worst enemy that we
have and so you manufacture this and
then everybody you know I think they
thought they could conjure up the old
days of you know the beating the war
drums that would bring people together
and enrich the people who are getting uh
rich
zelenski is literally a clown
he was a comedian on a comedy show and
there's like viral clips of him playing
guitar naked on stage or like pretending
to be naked I was going apparently
pretty funny guy I never saw I don't
speak Ukraine yeah that's fine he's
probably a funny guy dancing and he was
uh he played a character on a TV show
about a comedian that became president
or something like that and then he
became president and it's just like and
deep down he wants to be loved All
actors do this obsession with being
liked which is why I think we could make
a hero out of him if he ends this war if
there's enough public support for it he
won't throw his life at it it works for
him as the puppet candidate because he
can speak you need someone who can stand
up and do the the propaganda shots and
everything that's for sure remember
those videos that came out that looked
like they were cgi'd it's like he would
like the trees weren't moving behind him
and then they're like no those are real
it's just the lighting is weird because
uh but they put spotlights on him it's
like yo the trees aren't moving either
people believe that stuff do you think
that if we were talking about Trump
earlier that if he ran again or I think
he's going to or I don't know Trump
already declared a while ago I haven't
heard from him in about a month and a
half uh or something like that so the
the media is just going to be like hey
Putin's friends trying to run for
president again
we can't let him we can't let Putin's
buddy get president or he'll give Russia
to all of Europe and and uh how can that
possibly be overcome the liberal
economic orders Stranglehold on the
liberal on the Medias so like shows like
this you think share this show with your
friends if you think the liberal media
is bad he doesn't have a point
smooth it's going to be a rough sell on
people because they're gonna have to get
what 51 of the voting population to go
for this it's decentralization
um look man Don lemon's melting down
because his show is crumbling CNN's
losing whatever grip they had Zucker is
out these these big networks they're
struggling to maintain the narrative
it's you know it's almost like we're
getting we talked about the time machine
what was it called the two different
species of humans one were like trolls
and one were like super smart or
whatever more locks
I forget the name something like that it
feels like that's what we're going
because right now you know to shout out
that podcast again which is just getting
fire Eclipse these women This Woman's
like
he asks are are you a feminist she's
like yeah I'm a feminist because like
the system is you know like this this
women should be
awesome and I'm just like holy holy crap
that's a Biden voter right there and
then this everybody watching here is a
trump voter maybe some DeSantis voters
because like there's a logical decision
to be made about the capabilities of
either man but there's no decision to be
made about Biden anybody who spends five
seconds reading is gonna be like this
man is not qualified to be president
period or I should say he should he just
be kept far away from Office his brain
don't work yeah but what we're getting
is these people who are just like I
don't know like I saw on the TV they
said Donald Trump was Russian and Russia
is like in Mexico and so we shouldn't I
don't want a Mexico president and then
you like have you seen these fleckers
talks things they do I haven't seen the
Plagueis talks but I I I know what
you're talking about they go down and
they'll ask a random person name name a
country that's name starts with the
letter U and they'll go uh Utah
and it's like I know dumb people exist
and you can find them and make videos
mocking them but I'm just growing
concerned that you know that let's talk
about the lab League thing real quick
back and then we'll get into it in a bit
it's just like Seamus coggle and put it
really well Freedom Tunes guys shout out
he said Remember When a virus emerged in
right next a virus emerged in the city
that had a virus Factory and it merged
right next to the virus Factory but they
called you crazy for believing yeah that
it didn't come from the market a few
blocks away it's just like Jon Stewart
talked about that and he was just like
it's crazy they called him racist and
alt-right there are people that are so
dumb that zelenski can go on TV and I'm
driving down the street in West Virginia
and I see the Ukrainian Flags there
there's and West Virginia Virginia
Maryland there are people who they they
can't even point to Ukraine on a map and
they're like agreeing with a hundred
billion dollars in war funding for a
country they've never heard of
it's similar to voting against someone
which has been a big problem the last
five years is that people want to vote
against the guy they don't like not
right now they're fighting against
Russia it's not even for Ukraine I think
the Ukraine flag means we're afraid
Russia is going to take over Europe
they've just been scared to believe it
I don't know I guess the the goal with
the EU
is they want to make it just like the
United States they want it to be a large
centrally controlled block of different
economic regions right and so the more
they can induct other countries into it
Ukraine of course they they want Ukraine
in the EU the problem is their economy
is too bad so they're going to go with
NATO first Russia is like no way I'm not
letting you do this you're basically
taking over you know the funny thing
about Russia is there's a funny viral
video from a long time ago where this
woman is like
she's explaining that Russians are Asian
and they're like no they're not it's
like yes they are Russia is north of
China and like you can't and then
there's another video where like Indian
women are explaining that they're Asians
because India's in Asia and then people
like no you can't say that but I
remember I was talking to a friend and I
mentioned that Russia Russia Russians
were Russia was in Asia in fact most of
Russia is in Asia and then you have like
the Eastern portion what is it the west
of that mountain range the Euro
mountains do you think so yeah and um
you know west of it is Europe and then
east of it but most of Russia is in Asia
and then I had to explain to them I'm
like Russia is like 50 miles from Japan
and it's north of China yeah people
don't know how big this place is they
don't know what its interests are all
they know is
you know I don't know Communists from
the Soviet era or something I don't even
think that they they have a concept of
that I think that it's it's it's a far
more simplistic view of uh of Russia you
know it's the narrative is that Russia
is uh you know
is
among the basket of the of deplorables
essentially you know obviously Russia is
um an authoritarian Run state but
it's the the way that they've aligned
Donald Trump Russia and and essentially
anyone that has that has a dissenting
opinion in the United States is smeared
with the Russian
puppet uh narrative
um isn't zelenski getting rid of a bunch
of people though too he purged some of
his leaders defense ministers or Finance
ministers or
I mean he's doing his fair share I think
of crushing political discipline in his
own country yeah shut down media and
shut down a television
I believe churches associated with
Russia yeah Russia North Dallas right so
yeah which I mean obviously that's
that's stuff that that the media in the
US doesn't want to talk about because
it's a liberal behavior and they want to
paint
um zielinski is a Democrat a democratic
uh government that that we can rely on
as a stable partner
um and they ignore the fact that Ukraine
was one of the most corrupt countries in
Europe uh Eastern Europe is terribly
corrupt they didn't handle the
transition from Soviet states to Liberal
democracies uh the way that uh the
United States did
um it was significantly more corrupt and
and uh
Run for the oligarchs really that were
that whoever could grab power at the end
of the Soviet Union so the
the situation in the Ukraine is not it's
not the US's business well let's uh
let's talk about the escalation of War
because we got this year's story from
the Daily Mail FBI director agrees with
energy Department report that kovid most
likely leaked from Wuhan lab and claims
China is thwarting and obfuscating U.S
investigations into the virus so uh okay
uh shout out to Colbert because he
actually pointed this out in his bit
although he was trying to be dismissive
he said the raise in the department of
energy is putting out a statement on the
lab leak is because they actually
oversee biolabs so a lot of people are
you know Jon Stewart made a joke when
asked about he's like I wasn't waiting
for the Department of energy to weigh in
on this one they'll laugh and it's like
well they actually are the authority as
they oversee biolabs and uh the FBI
director uh Christopher Wright agrees
the lab leak about this so what's the
debate now what's the argument can we
just tell all of these crackpot liberal
people in the corporate press they were
wrong and and they should be fired or
what
Fireball uh for other reasons I guess
we're reporting what they were told so I
don't know if you I don't know so is
that so so wait wait so you know I hire
a reporter and then I'm like go report
on what's going on the pandemic and then
after you do I'll tell you what to write
yeah basically that's how those
corporations work it's true but yeah I
mean those aren't journalists and they
should their their PR spokesman for
powerful institutions they're reporting
they're not investigating well like
everything it goes back to Trump because
Trump was the one who said this virus is
from China suggested that this was the
source of it and so the media and their
reflexive uh Behavior then of course had
to come out and say no
that that's not it
um and so they had just dug their heels
in and there wasn't a lot of reporting
on this until
um you know not even this Revelation
there were others stepping forward do
you think it was Trump
he called it the China virus right away
I mean a lot of people were blaming
China but Trump was a very loud and
prominent voice very early on blaming
China he was critical in China early
early in his he was always critical of
China
do you think that that was the
motivation behind the push against the
The Narrative that it was a a Wu and
there's a really that it was
manufactured there's a really great
video where there's this Doctor Who says
the reason people didn't work the reason
the Press ignored the lab League stuff
is because we funded the lab and it was
embarrassing and if we didn't fund it it
would be 100 of Americans agreeing it
most likely came from the lab but it's
it's insane that uh I mean the video is
fantastic it's insane that the media
literally said this and I have people
repeating it to me I had a friend be
like no I think it probably came from
the wet Market I'm like you think the
bat coronavirus didn't come from the bat
coronavirus laboratory it came from the
wet Market a block away from the
laboratory where someone drove a bat
from a thousand miles away to eat
instead of the lab where they had the
actual viruses that I you know that's
how I that's how I feel too I don't I
think that Donald Trump would get
pushback no matter what but I think that
because the U.S government was funding
the lab in Wuhan and the covet virus
likely came from the lab in Wuhan that
that is going to make the narrative
pushback
doesn't mean we can call the China virus
now I mean I don't see a problem with it
but someone's going to say you're a
racist I'm part Asian so I'm allowed to
and you're racist if you tell me I can't
okay yeah but I don't even know white
liberals coming to me and telling me
what my people are allowed to say that's
racist you know I'm I'm trying to have a
conversation over here yeah but uh
they'll call Larry aldera white
supremacist so you know they'll just
they're gonna call you they're going to
call it whatever it's just no matter
what I mean it doesn't matter like it
doesn't matter what you say because
they're they're going to call you names
and they're going to frame it in in a
way that can slime you no matter what I
I think dirty smear Merchants as we've
mentioned this in the past couple of
nights I think the US is getting ready
for war with China and they need this
narrative I don't think so because they
were working together on bioweapons in
Wuhan so I and and no one we're like
Neighbors in the Pacific so I I don't
think so I don't think yeah with Russia
with like Alaska and Russia China and
Russia all being kind of like that very
large area that you're thinking of and
we're not we're not neighbors You could
argue we're neighbors everywhere in the
world because the hegemonic powers are
pressing against each other's borders
but like we're all neighbors it's like
yeah and shooting at each other but sure
neighbors like Pakistan and India are
neighbors they've got Pacific Coast
access any any of these Pacific uh
countries I would consider like our West
Coast neighbors like sure but like
Australia China is our principal
adversary and they've been like sending
warships into our territorial like near
or just outside of our territorial
Waters Alaska and Hawaii I think they're
deathly afraid we're gonna invade China
you think China's scared the US will
invade gently afraid I think that makes
you say that really because they're like
a crumbling economy with just just using
us as their their greatest sales agent
set up for people if we cancel our
alliance with China they they go
bankrupt that's one that's different or
trade lines that is different to
invading mainland and China I think
that's the fear of most people around
the world is that the United States is
going to invade no like that's not China
that's not even that is so that is so
outside of the the realm of possibility
there's there's I mean actually maybe
maybe that's why because it's the least
likely thing I figured it out I figured
it out here's what we gotta do America
Americans got guns right yes the U.S
just needs to build like a land bridge
to China and then tell Americans go yeah
and because you know here's what I was
thinking the the Chinese people have no
guns and so if you took every American
citizen and just plopped it right on top
of China like instantly the Americans
would take over and own the place
because we got so many guns if they have
no guns what are we going there for well
because I was thinking like they don't
have oil we wouldn't invade they have
Rare Earth Rare Earth mines Rare Earth
minerals are actually everywhere but
just China's got the industry but um if
the U.S was going to invade John I
thought it was I was thinking about this
and I'm like yeah why doesn't anybody
invade the US well it's obvious
obviously because there's a gun behind
every blade of grass but not in China
they've got the the a big army they have
the largest ground uh standing ground
Army but that won't matter when you have
how many people are in their army not
300 million let's say you take 100
million U.S adult men with guns
you know it's a hell weather to the
country don't win any War like it's all
the men China is a very weak militarily
they have good technology but their
their citizens are like malnourished and
impotent they have a billion and a half
people fighting with backhoes and stuff
it doesn't matter
if they don't have weapons if they don't
have ballistics important side point
that people are bringing up Adrian Curry
just said avoid Discord they'll ban you
yeah we need to find something other
than Discord right there's another uh
there's something out there that's an
option I forget the name of the the
company that runs it well we'll figure
it out Matrix is one uh The Matrix
protocol like element element chat but
it's pretty it can be pretty buggy right
I mean rumble's working on something for
us so we'll see what they can hook up
yeah oh you think Rumble will make a
colon function or something yeah I think
they're literally building something for
us because we need something bespoke so
well if that's the case Rumble should
build Channel chats and then we can
embed the channel chat on all of the
content so there's always a chat room
available everywhere 24 7. hey that's a
good idea I like that yeah gilded is the
name of the other the other uh company
that I was thinking of gilded yeah they
do essentially the same thing as Discord
but I bring up this China stuff because
I think that as Americans we've been
like indoctrinated by lit to live in
fear of other people since uh 911
basically I've seen it pretty intensely
and I don't think that anyone has any
intention of invading the United States
right now to be like poking the bear and
and I mean look at what we did with NATO
how we pushed it right up to the Russian
border and then blame them for for
moving forward like it's like putting
turrets right you were yeah putting a
bunch of turrets right outside someone's
front door yeah
I don't think any of it is serious
because these aren't serious people
including the people who are running our
military people who are in charge here
and everywhere else they're just not
serious they're not capable people are
you saying that you don't think anything
serious
look at this to do what beyond what he's
already doing
I love this meme I don't think he wants
to invade the US no he doesn't I I agree
with that or I don't think he wants to
invade Poland I don't think he wants to
invade anywhere this is a good example
of us thinking that the Iranians are a
threat Iranians are a threat to the
United States it's a meme where it says
Iran wants war look how close they put
their country to our military bases and
then it shows all of the US military
bases surrounding Iran yeah I don't
think that the United States is at any
threat to anyone but themselves at this
point well the U.S is a threat to a lot
of people around the world yeah well I
mean there is no threat to the United
States Beyond themselves at this point
if we implode and rip our country apart
that's the end of America otherwise
what's happening and you know what
whatever that's why I'm saying look the
argument for Trump the argument about
Trump was that if you revert to
nationalism and you reduce
internationalism secure the borders
bring manufacturing back it's it's
semi-isolationist I'm not saying you cut
yourself off from the world but what
happens then is the petrodollar crumbles
the U.S becomes reliant on its
manufacturing base to do trib with other
countries instead of military might and
uh so my attitude was like look if you
like the way you live where you don't
you can write articles about you know
celebrity gossip and get paid 60k a year
then you want to vote neolib you want to
vote neocon you want to vote
establishment because bombing kids in
Yemen sells weapons to Saudi Arabia
which props up our economy and then you
get to do nothing for everything but if
you vote for Donald Trump you're gonna
have to rub your sleeves get a good job
take care of yourself figure things out
on your own and you're not going to get
this free ride from blowing up kids
Donald Trump's foreign policy I think
proves that and I've always been about
the U.S should not be using military
might for economic Advantage around the
world but I tell you this all these
leftists and all these liberals if you
actually place them in front of like a
fork in the road and you said the fork
on the left ends all war
from the United States and the Empire
but you'll have to work from sun up to
sun down on a farm to survive and the
road on the right we blow those kids up
but you get cheap cheeseburgers they
will all walk down the Right Fork every
single hipster College leftist will take
the go ahead and blow them off if it
means I don't gotta work because already
we're seeing these videos of young
people being like they're filming
themselves on Tick Tock going why do I
have to work to like live
adulting yeah yeah the word adult thing
full term oh boy let's talk about how
bad things uh are in this uh in this
this country here we got this tweet
front for you I tweeted this out this
morning if you take the Chicago election
results map and place it over a racial
demographics map what you get is
probably unsurprising black
neighborhoods voted for Lightfoot a
black woman Hispanic neighbors voted for
Garcia Hispanic and white neighborhoods
voted for uh Valles and some Johnson
Valles is a white guy now it's not
absolute Johnson is a black man as well
but this is a fascinating thing here's
the map you can see and uh the maroon is
Valles a white man the uh burnt orangish
is Johnson who is a black man the purple
is Lightfoot you know Lori Lightfoot
they call her Beetlejuice and the green
is Garcia now you may notice that
there's a big chunk of green here and
green here well let's uh let's start
with this here is the here's a map of
you know it's really annoying that the
wait wait let me see if I can uh
shrink this down somehow no actually I
can't oh a little bit maybe it can't
scroll won't let me scroll so uh oh well
it is what it is actually maybe I can do
this
there we go and now I can shrink it yeah
all right nope still didn't work all
right never mind so you take a look at
this you know what we'll just we'll just
go right for the map here you go here's
here's here's the race and ethnicity in
Chicago map
and uh here's White
you can see up here on the top left Nero
here it's all white you can see here
it's it's moderately what you can see
right here it's all white you can see
down here there's some white you can see
here and here and uh and then let's take
a look at the Electoral election results
map hey look at that the white area the
white area the white area they all voted
for a White Guy take a look at this
let's go back and check out Hispanic
here you got a big chunk right here in
the middle right here and down here and
what do you see go back to the electoral
map hey look at that right in the same
place they voted for the hispanic guy
now hold on Ward 10 you might say voted
for the white guy ah yes but 36 for
valus the white guy in 35 percent for
Jesus G Garcia the hispanic guy in a
neighborhood that is mixed between white
and Hispanic they voted mix and then of
course if you go back to the racial
demographic Maps Maps and look at black
you'll see this whole area is black
community and right here as well and
then you look at the electoral map and
sure enough
the only thing that apparently mattered
to people in Chicago was the race of the
candidate how about that I'm sure a lot
of people were concerned about policy
I'm sure a lot of people if you take a
look at this area Logan Square up to
Rogers Park this is the Hipster portion
that's wokeness these are the woke left
people and they voted for Johnson and
he's to the left of Lightfoot there you
go he's the last one yeah so for them
it's policy but they're also racist so
I'm unsurprised so there you go right
yeah I I was looking at the map and the
breakdown and I was wondering like why
did Lori Lightfoot lose she's an awful
mayor and here's the thing everybody's
talking about like oh wow she came in
third place she got defeated in a
landslide no she didn't she got the same
amount of votes she got last time
the only difference this time white
people voted wow they're locked out
they're shut down so I call them crime
and there were eight crime as a result
of the shout outs vallis ran almost
exclusively on crime crime as a result
of a cabin well I mean a lot of things
but you look at his website and he's got
a tab on the menu bar for issues and
then right next to it is crime and then
he's got a report crime so his campaign
website was encouraging voters to report
crimes to him that's how much crime
motivated white people to vote well and
what you're talking about you know this
because you're from Chicago and I I can
say I'm from Chicago or I cannot say it
not that I'm outside okay suburban
Chicago I spent enough time there
um but that pink area to the right
um is I mean that's a lot of lib white
woke women in that area so Lincoln Park
so the loop up north oh yeah through
Gold Coast Gold Coast Linkin Park you
know Wrigleyville that and then you
start to get into the uh Johnson's area
there
um you know that that's the wealthiest
part of the city yep so
but even here in the southwest but
that's also an area that has always
really been immune to Crime the Gold
Coast Lincoln Park I mean and that just
has not been the case so people who've
lived there safely thought they could
walk to the restaurants you know that's
you know I looked up the Gold Coast I
mean it's like it's it's locked down
yeah I looked up Lori lightfoot's
election results and she got like 88 000
votes in the last election which one or
one wins which one the first one the
previous election and then this time
around she got uh I think what did she
get uh no no she got like 92. she got 87
000 votes this time around putting her
in third place if she got only a few
thousand more she would have beat
Brandon Johnson
and then if she she needed what nine
thousand no not even seven thousand more
not even seven thousand I'm sorry
seventeen thousand my bad about 17 000
more votes and she would be in the
runoff with Paul vallis and that's what
happened last time she got around 90 000
votes went into a runoff and then she
won my prediction Brandon Johnson wins
okay based on this map showing you that
the black neighborhoods voted for the
for for uh if you look at the the black
neighborhoods the top candidates votes
Lori Lightfoot Willie Wilson and Brandon
Johnson the top three they're all black
if you look at the white areas it's Paul
vallas Brandon Johnson Jesus Garcia it's
mixed my prediction is the black
neighborhoods will likely vote for the
black candidate in the runoff not the
white guy giving Brandon Johnson the the
tremendous Advantage just uh to win so
it's kind of disheartening to be
completely honest that you look at like
the Hispanic neighborhoods and they just
vote for the hispanic guy and the white
neighbors voted for the white guy and
the black neighbors voted for the black
lady so what do you think is going to
happen then you're gonna get here's my
prediction in the future I think we're
going to start seeing a tremendous
amount of black politicians and to a
lesser degree Hispanic and Asian but a
tremendous amount and the reason is
conservatives don't care about race if
you have a Larry Elder or Thomas Sowell
conservatives are gonna be clapping and
cheering for him they don't care what
his race is they care about the policies
and the ideas the Liberals and the left
are extremely racist they won't vote for
a White Guy which writes real problems
for the Democratic party that's why they
you know want a Kamala hair or something
like that so what will end up happening
is you're going to have in this scenario
is a perfect example Brandon Johnson
don't know his policies don't anything
about him but if we're seeing
by neighborhood people vote
predominantly based on race
what's going to happen
white people will be split between
vallison and Johnson because you're
going to get a mix of the college
liberal types in Logan Square Rogers
Park who are racist who won't vote for a
white guy then you'll get the more urban
conservative types who will vote for the
tough on crime guy then you'll get the
black neighborhoods voting for the black
candidate and you will ultimately end up
with more black candidates winning in
the long run also when a white person a
black person have a baby they have a
black baby they call it mixed but like
Barack Obama you call him a black guy
this is a white mother and this is
something that I was told since I was a
little kid being mixed race I was told
that on the on the census I am not a
white person that the the even though
I'm 75 white according to the US
government I am not white that's how it
works so I'm like I I don't I don't know
but my point ultimately is this if
conservatives are not racist and they're
willing to vote for anybody
and the left is only willing to vote for
minorities that's going to create a
tremendous pressure in One Direction
away from White candidates well I think
in Chicago and Johnson is far more
Progressive even more so than she is I
think he wants a city income tax I think
he's defund the police guy uh he's was
bolstered by the Chicago Teachers Union
the most powerful political interest
group in the City by far and I think
after crime education is a huge one you
have hugely dropping
attendance and
participation rates in Chicago Public
Schools especially after lockdowns and
of course Chicago public schools had one
of the longest lockdowns and Paul of
Alice so education is a big issue
Paul vallis is the former education
secretary in the city he worked for Rich
Daly I believe he was his education you
wouldn't call it secretary head of
education so he's got a very strong
background I think he also was in Philly
in a few other cities
so I think that that is sort of his
Advantage but I think you know it wasn't
that long ago Chicago you know they
voted for Rahm Emanuel obviously Rich
Haley won I don't know how many terms
four so you have Valas who is a Daily
Democrat which a lot of people nowadays
call Republicans
um versus a very far left
um uh candidate and Johnson so it's a
it's going to be a big you take a look
at these uh the black neighborhoods and
you can see that Lori Lightfoot Willie
Wilson and Brandon Johnson are all the
top in Ward six Lori Lightfoot has 38
Willie Wilson has 22 and Brandon Johnson
has 18.
that means when it goes to the runoff
why would they vote for vallis they're
going to vote for Johnson he's their
third pick not vallis he gets their vote
and so then you look at Ward 11 Valles
and Johnson are vallis is 58 to
Johnson's 14 to Garcia's 13 but I think
Johnson still gets an advantage there
you take a look at the woke areas I I
trust me guys if you don't know Logan
Square is I used to live there that's
right me too young Northwestern is up
north of here that's right and you got
like Loyola up here as well and so
Brandon Johnson is already winning in
these places so then you look at this
over here Brandon Johnson's got 19 valve
has 50 I think you give all of the all
of these areas already leaning slightly
towards him plus take a look at the vote
Lori Lightfoot and Willie Wilson's votes
if you take 87 let's just call it 90
plus 45 so you're taking uh an extra 100
and you know 40 000 votes on top of
Brandon Johnson he crushes of Alice I
don't see Val is picking up the the rest
of the votes and I'm gonna say it I
don't care what what the left says you
can clearly look at these maps and see
that people were just voting for the
race of the individual that's it it
makes but you know what it could be it
could be simply put if you're a guy if
you're if you're from Little Village if
you're from Ward 12 and you're Hispanic
you know that Community better so it
makes sense when you're campaigning and
saying stuff like hey I'm gonna help
with these issues the people who live
there are like hey those are issues I
know and so Lori Lightfoot knows these
areas but as much as I think it's fair
to say there's a component there I
really do think for the most part the
people in Chicago have proven they're
simply voting based on race now for the
people who are voting for Paul vallis
this is what I was saying I think
conservatives for the most part don't
care they're just like if you're tough
on crime I'll vote for you Lori lifewood
is not a fun crime that's why you can
see up in these areas Johnson gets a
portion of the vote and valus gets a
portion of the vote he gets the most of
the vote but I think what I just think
it's clear as they right there that
people just care about racism well it's
it's definitely really you're right your
observation is correct that it is based
you know racially how it's segregated is
how it was voted but correlation is not
a proof of causation so it's you know
keep that in mind when making claims
about why people voted sure and that's
why I said there's a possibility that
you know Garcia
gives a campaign speech
and because his experience comes in the
same neighborhood it resonates with
people in that neighborhood does he
speak Spanish
that's a big who yes
his real name is Chewie I I think it's
something else but that's what they call
him so if people say if you speak
Spanish or your parents are like you're
from Mexico or something like that that
I could see why you would vote for
someone that also spokes oh for sure I
mean he's been around I mean look man
there's a reason why everybody lives
next to the people of the same there's a
reason why the neighborhoods are all
segregated people choose to do that the
government like redlining and
blockbusting ended blockbusting in the
80s red lighting ended a long time ago
people now just choose to live next to
people who they look like and look like
them
so this this like
I think that the Democrat critical race
Theory leftist stuff makes this worse
and is exacerbating it absolutely
absolutely I believe that the whole like
let's let's get a woman of color as our
vice president like that obsession with
race and gender or I guess sex and race
you're gonna see it all over the place I
mean Chicago's always but it's been a
city whose politics has been run by race
for a long time I mean you go back to
the days of Harold Washington and you
know that whole Wars of the early 1980s
um that was uh you know when he was the
first black elected mayor I think in the
country maybe he was the second
um so it's not necessarily new but I I
don't know I'm going to disagree a
little bit I think I think there's
different Dynamics you think for the
runoff than just race I think there's I
just think it's a far more
um complicated complex
based maybe I'm being naive what do you
think what else do you think I I I think
education Paul of Alice his roots to the
city you know he's not like the old
business guy or say a Rahm Emanuel or
somewhere he's got he's got good
credibility and a good background in
what he's done for the city and I do
think his background in education
um you know crime being the major issue
there I think uh what's happening in the
schools is a major issue to to a lot of
these parents now I I mean I don't think
I'd be naive enough to think that you
know a lot of those neighborhoods a lot
of those Wards regardless of what
situation they're in would consider
voting for valus
um but I do think it's a little bit more
nuanced I think than race
I think that obviously there's a lot of
things that play a role when you look at
the Rogers Park stuff these are clearly
you know more white areas that are
voting for a black man obviously for but
that that falls in line with that um
there was a study done that shows the
different racial breakdowns in their
in-group out group preference and white
liberal is the only group with an app
Group preference makes perfect sense
when you look at this that's right so
these neighborhoods they probably care
to a certain degree about policy but I
mean you look at some of these places
and it's like you know in Ward 18 which
is I believe Ford's it's probably Ford
City area okay you've got actually let's
just do this
it's uh uh so here we go it's Ford City
you've got 15 or so uh white population
and I'm sorry that's a black population
it's uh 27 22 you know percent white it
really does correlate like this area is
split between White Lies mixed so you
get Lori Lightfoot then Paul vallis but
then you go into the areas that are more
heavily black and it's Lori Lightfoot
Willie Wilson and Brandon Johnson like
even Johnson who's far left it seems
like race played a bigger role than
anything else so I'm sure you could
probably say 40 of the vote is is due to
good policy but because of race being a
predominant issue for most people I
guess the way they see the world that
ended up being the dominant Factor
because that's what manifested in the
map you can come out and be like no no
everyone voted on policy and I'm like
yeah but if you look at the map it's
near one for one with the racial
breakdowns of the city and who they
voted for
that's kind of disheartening in it yes
maybe that's just reality you know you
can't feel one way or the other about it
I was thinking the other yesterday or
today something like when we talk about
race like you got did people say white
and black is a race but it's the only
ones that aren't like uh a country I
think I mean there's Latino but is that
a race Asians Asian Asians are continent
like so there's there's a Russian
they're they're they're from Russia or
like Caucasian the Caucasus then all of
a sudden you have black and white which
are like what how's that there's black
people all over the world from Haiti and
from Africa and from you know East East
Asia and things like that so like what I
don't know the I don't understand race
the whole concept of race is very weird
let's jump to uh some pop culture news
and something completely uh off the
I don't know out of our normal subject
range I guess but actually maybe it's
not here's a story from the Daily Mail
healing comes first fans send Justin
Bieber well wishes as he cancels the
remainder of his Justice World Tour amid
Health woes that's right uh did you guys
know that his face is paralyzed and uh
people are saying that they believe the
reason that he's canceling is because he
can't use his face anymore and uh
they're saying it's Ramsay Hunt syndrome
and Phil's giving me this look right now
you you
phrased it you can't use your face
anymore oh I mean I don't know what he's
funny to me so uh you know here's this
29 year old dude suffering from
something they that they say that
typically only affects people over the
age of 60. he's still affected by this
this was like three months ago I think
he he first announced it this is I guess
what the it's being reported by a bunch
of celebrity gossip and Outlets that's
the reason the Ramsay Hunt Syndrome like
where we saw this a while ago he his
face was paralyzed but it causes it well
uh they're saying it's Ramsay Hunt a lot
of people thought it was uh what Bell's
Palsy okay caused by probably some kind
of medication perhaps a medication
perhaps that he was he was prescribed in
order to travel the world maybe adverse
reaction or something maybe some yeah to
some kind of medication but uh we don't
know for sure recreational use of
medication I mean that that's possible
too to be honest all of the above but
they're saying it's chickenpox
they're saying that uh and you know I it
makes perfect sense yeah right because
we just heard that MSNBC host got
pericarditis and myocarditis from the
common cold so as we as we know that
these very common uh ailments can cause
things like
facial paralysis and swelling of the
lining around the heart
so it happens all the time I've learned
a lot since 2020. that's right did oh
and heart attacks and strokes are way up
among young people and they're saying
that's caused by erythritol yeah yeah
I've heard I've heard that's right yeah
all these keto diets so you know
Was it chicken oh and chicken eggs they
say we're causing that too you know we
we learned a whole lot about the world
and maybe if we cut out erythritol
chicken eggs avoid chicken pox in the
common cold these heart attacks strokes
and pericarditis and myocarditis will
stop happening and you know maybe Justin
Bieber's cracking raw eggs for breakfast
and you see he's doing keto diet so he's
eating a lot of egg and he's eating a
lot erythritol he should have just
stayed in the pot he'd have been safe in
the Pod man well you know maybe did he
ever say why he thinks he got sick with
this did he ever
say like I had adverse reaction to
something or any of that or did he just
say
I think I think he said Ramsay Hunt
which they say it's like oh he's got
chickenpox and the virus hit the nerve
in his ear or something and then it
paralyzes your face and makes you go
deaf is it permanent uh I
don't really recover from right yeah
there's like a viral video of some nurse
or something that got Bell's Palsy from
I believe from some sort of vaccination
I'm not sure I'm not sure which one I'm
not sure which one no just some sort of
vaccination though but then it goes away
so it's like temporary paralysis of the
face or something like that so you know
I don't know I thought it was kind of a
big deal that one of the biggest
celebrities in the world canceled a
world tour this is one of the most
famous guys
and it's it's you know what's funny is
uh Eric Clapton's hands got paralyzed
you remember that you don't say yeah
early on in the pandemic I don't even
like call it a pandemic man that's so
gross it's just so weird all of these
things are happening around the same
time and uh
you know I gotta say talk to a doctor
about what's right for you and don't get
your medical advice from podcasters but
I honestly think there's a strong
possibility that the next big Domino to
fall will be Mass vaccination
specific specific mass vaccination not
you know I think there's a lot of
vaccines that have been around for a
long time that have been tested over
several decades but I wouldn't be
surprised if come 2024 you're going to
see some news come out about
Adverse Events The increased risk we've
already started seeing reports that
young people are seeing an increase of
risk of myocarditis and pericarditis
despite the fact they're saying it's
caused by the common cold or whatever
they might say and then I wouldn't be
surprised if Donald Trump is running for
president and they say oh yeah you know
all these really bad things we're
showing you like Justin Bieber oh no oh
that's Trump's fault that was that was
Trump's fault is Donald Trump's uh
yeah his vaccine
yep blame his vaccine don't blame him
and then they're not going to vote for
him it was because of warps and that's
how you convince convince conservatives
not to support Trump and then they'll
get behind DeSantis what do you guys
think of Vivek Rama Swami as a political
candidate I don't think he's going to
win but he seems like an all right dude
yeah I don't know enough about him to to
have a uh a formed opinion like a solid
opinion but uh the things that I have
heard are appealing the reason I bring
it up is because I'm I'm absolutely
disheartened by the way Donald Trump
handled the the uh covet stuff like he
he just handed it off to fauci in the
administrative State and then like was
like that's why I didn't even tell
people to go outside and get fresh air
or any of that that's why I think this
is the direction things will go that
they're gonna Something's Gonna Change
in the news we're already getting the
FBI and the doe saying Washington State
Department of energy saying that lab
leak is most likely the case which is in
a sense vindicating for Trump but then
they're going to come out and they're
going to be like yeah all these bad
things that was Trump's fault he doubled
down he wouldn't back off fauci who lied
lab leak Donald Trump that was under him
and so what's going to happen DeSantis
is going to win
we'll see well I mean I was very
critical of trump from the very start
even the 15 days to stop the spread or
whatever they called it flatten the
curve
um highly critical of him uh and handing
over basically the economy and the
entire government of fauci and Deborah
Burks and using highly flawed models
that were not tested as evidence to per
to continue the lockdowns then into
April of of 2020.
um and he really I mean I think he's
come out and said
he's expressed some regret but of course
he owns operation warp speed and you
have not seen him pull back on that at
all off of that at all
but DeSantis also
did go along with the lockdowns early on
he went along with some other mitigation
factors including the vaccine so his
hands are not totally clean I mean he
has expressed more regret I think and
talked about the lessons that he learned
but look I was I was in Florida at the
beginning of the lockdown I mean it was
it was locked out yeah and gradually
reopening and he was signing executive
emergency you know declaration so
um if they're going to battle over that
I think ultimately DeSantis prevails
because he did come around and he did
open his State a little bit sooner than
others and that's the look The
Establishment we'll take it to Santa's
over a trump
really absolutely absolutely Democrats I
talked to they hate the sanctions sure
she watches Trump I mean they're gunning
for that guy already they want to win
right though they want to win but they
will take it to chance over Trump
State yeah I'm not saying that they're
going to come out and be alike I'm
voting for DeSantis they're going to
come out and be like DeSantis is as bad
as Trump then when it comes to the
election they will put everything into
helping DeSantis win the primary to stop
Trump because if it came down to
Democrats losing they would prefer to
send us over Trump
easily do you think that do you think
santis or who do you think is more
beatable Trump or DeSantis from it from
a from a left-leaning perspective I
think I think well it's tough right now
right the Sanders has an advantage in a
lot of ways but he doesn't really have
that X Factor that Trump has that's
right and the the whole East Palestine
thing was very very good for Trump who's
Trump got as his advisors right now
because I think kushner's out and
ivanka's not involved as far as I can
tell so who like advised Donald to go to
Palestine East Palestine or did he make
that decision my guess is he made it on
his own I mean I do think that that's
was part of his charm and success and
continues to be is that he would be the
one no one would really have to tell him
to do that you know he he would do it on
his own in terms of his advisors I'm I'm
not really sure he's around him now I
think Vivek Rama Swami is a serious
candidate in that he's actually talking
about how to solve the situation which
is to put our our economy into uh uh
what are they called uh
damn it man uh basically to invest our
401ks into non-woke organizations oh
anti-esg yes that is his main thing it's
not even he doesn't even I mean he is
anti-est but he's actually talking about
how to succeed he's not talking about
let's stop doing ESG like that's part of
it but he's telling you what to do and
he's done it he's been doing it so it's
like he'd be a fantastic maybe not a
military commander I don't know anything
about his foreign policy but I think if
if maybe a vice president because he's a
brilliant Economist the Pres the vice
president doesn't really have a whole
lot of a job to actually do and someone
like Vivek if he's got good ideas
someone like that might be better off in
a in a an Administration position where
they're writing policy where they're
actually crafting the policy Donald
Trump is good has good gut instincts but
the things that that had
tangible effect on the the
the economy and and policy those were
almost all written by other people
Donald Trump's not a policy guy he's a
big picture dude he's he's going to be
like go do this let's get this done the
anti-woke uh executive order that he
wrote that he signed that was written by
people like James Lindsay and and stuff
that that knew how to craft policy that
will achieve the ends that we want that
still is legal and is not straining the
law because we really do have a lot of
the tools at our disposal to to fix a
lot of the problems that we have so I
like Vivek but I don't think that he
would I don't know that he this alone is
enough for him for me to say that he
would make a good president it's not
exciting it's not nothing about going
anti-sja or fixing the economy is not
exciting it's yelling and calling people
names and making a big to do the ESG
stuff is the most important stuff going
right now it's not exciting you're right
but it is the most it will have the most
impact on this on society and it's the
most important thing to to it's it's the
economy if it kind of goes bad violence
will increase if you want to stop
violence fix the economy if you want to
make sure people don't starve and Rob
each other fix the economy you know what
Trump needs to do I was thinking about
that whatever podcast that keeps getting
these viral Clips that's probably going
to become a massive show but you know
it's got its market cap and and that
joke where someone said get a bunch of
low-wit narcissistic women and you know
rag on them you'll have a great show
that's the strategy right there for
Trump get Democrats who are of low wit
and sound really dumb and debate them
it's it's why why debate
smart people when you just make yourself
look dumb get into debate stage with
stupid people and then it makes you look
really smart whether you're smart or not
you know what I mean like Trump needs to
put himself in positions where he's
debating really really dumb people so he
should offer up conversations with with
smaller channels and smaller podcasts
from the left that would kill for an
opportunity at the Limelight but there's
a reason why they don't have it and I'm
only half kidding think about this you
find a YouTube channel with 50 70 000
Subs leftist liberal kind of articulate
guy or lady not really that smart Trump
says I will do an interview with you
you then get Trump running circles
around a leftist liberal making them
look like a and those liberals
will do it in two seconds because
they're like I'm gonna get to interview
Trump this is going to be huge and then
Trump ends up boosting in the polls
because he looks smart yeah I think even
if he Donald Trump were to to come out
and look stupid about stuff it wouldn't
like stop people from voting for him
they I think people would more
appreciate his honesty and openness look
he does these interviews with the
corporate press all the time and they're
they're they're playing him every time
it's like he doesn't learn his lesson he
sits down he says here's what's going on
I'm going to do these things it'll be
tremendous and then they're like okay
let me write that down Trump is Hitler
and hates black people and uh we'll run
that and then Trump goes back again
three months later you wrote a really
nasty piece about me but I'll give you
another chance so just Trump just just
go find the the up and comers who are
desperate for attention and then you
know do those interviews what are a few
interviews off top of your head you know
any what do you mean any like they fit
the bill are the ones like the um
whatever well whatever is huge no no I'm
saying
when you get like the guys who run that
podcast are clearly smart dudes who have
a successful business
and you put them in a table with a bunch
of vapid low-wit women they're not going
to be on the same level so you're going
to run circles around them in terms of
getting the sound bites that you want
that's what I'm saying Trump sits down
with some like low-wit liberals and then
they'll say something like would you you
were trying to dig up dirt on Joe Biden
it'll go dig up dirt don't you know that
Joe Biden withheld a billion dollars in
loan guarantees which is a violation of
federal law only Congress has the
authority to do that you didn't know
that did you and they're gonna go huh
and then that clip is going to go viral
and you're gonna have a really dumb low
it person and Trump's going to be just
I'd rather have him do that than keep
meeting with Maggie Haberman exactly
what's he doing come on who's Maggie
huberman
New York Times New York Times Reporter
yeah and then sharing a whole book about
him but he and also because he met with
her I think three times in 2021. and he
just keeps giving these corporate
journalists who are just like okay
Donald we're going to write negative
things about you thanks for your time
and he's like oh no
well I mean I do think that was one of
his Achilles heels is that even though
he would go after the media he still
wants their affection you know he still
thinks he could win them over and charm
them over even someone like Maggie
Haberman who sticks it in his back every
single time
um so has he learned that lesson I don't
know he just met with her
numerous times so encouraging
2021 she wrote an entire book on him
man yeah we got to get him in here or
I'll fly down there to wherever he's at
and interview him because I gotta know I
gotta know what is his state of mind
right now like
he wants to run for president what what
is he is running from he is running for
president as uh what's his plans like
what's what's his status what does he
want to do he's been releasing videos
you should watch them he's got a whole
bunch that he's put on Truth social
um they're on truth but I think they're
being posted other places like policy
stuff yeah yeah he like stands up and
he'll say something like the woke left
is destroying this country
four more years
that was really good the left and the
right racial politics divide divide like
that's the problem we gotta not do that
this time and do something new the
racial politics is something that we're
going to get regardless of whether it's
Donald Trump or whether it's DeSantis or
whatever because that is the the current
operating system of the left is racial
politics identity politics really
anytime the left can use identity as a
bludgeoning tool they're going to but my
theory is that your fighting an
alligator underwater if you do that if
you play their terms if you use their
words and their definitions you've lost
that you're fighting with like 180
percent deficiency value like you you've
got like 15 of your strength when you're
underwater fighting that thing that's
why Trump needs to stop giving these
people the opportunity and they need to
do Trump should do more shows like this
and he should do shows with smaller
liberals who are low it play it play you
know play where to your strengths go go
to Friendly territory where you might
get some honest criticism and push back
but you're mostly going to get a real
conversation and then go to places where
people aren't smart enough to deal with
you and I know the left will they'll
clip this out and be like Tim's Inc yes
of course it's called politics it's
winning you like Joe Biden hit in his
basement the entire campaign like that
dude was clearly not interested in
having any real conversation on ideas
well let me ask you Julie why we got you
let's move on and talk about
weaponization of government so one of
the big thing that's happening uh with
you know like Republicans taking
Congress is they've got this uh
committee on the weaponization of
government and uh you wrote a book about
it and what's going on with January 6th
so I'm curious if you think we're gonna
get any real resolution moving forward
or are we going to need to see like a
sweep of the federal government in 2024
with the Senate with the White House and
the house before we get any real action
I do think this will be another wedge
issue for Trump uh aside up from the
border and and the Ukraine war is you
know people's just crushing their lack
of faith in these institutions and not
just faith in them but that they are
recognizing they are completely corrupt
weaponized
um in a very highly partisan way against
the right you know you went from the FBI
going after Donald Trump in 2016 under
Crossfire hurricane going after his
campaign AIDS and Associates and now you
have the FBI rounding up people who
protested at the Capitol they're at
almost a thousand total criminal
defendants most of whom have been
charged with low-level misdemeanors like
parading in the capital
um the doj has said that they're going
to get up to 2 000 total defendants the
FBI is still investigating still a
thousand more people that they've got
yet wow they want to get to a total
caseload of at least 2 000. they are
arresting people every week the FBI is
still investigating uh conducting armed
raids of homes you know taking people
out of their homes and off to jail and
with these trumped up charges
um and so I think that that's going to
continue to be a a major issue you've
got at least a hundred men who have been
held under pre-trial detention orders
um for their non-violent some of them
non-violent offenders even the ones who
are charged with things like vandalizing
or assaulting police officers
I think what we will see and we are
seeing is that things like that scenes
like that that came out of January 6 are
not as cut and dry as the American
people have been led to believe and so I
think that's why you see this hysteria
over the release of Tucker Carlson and I
want to commend Kevin McCarthy for this
because he did follow up on a promise to
release the unreleased footage that was
captured by uh surveillance videos at
the Capitol not just the Capitol
building but other buildings and the
surrounding grounds that day that the
doj and Capitol Police have kept Under
Wraps under strict protective orders not
just from the American people but also
in court keeping them away from
defendants and their own attorneys do
you think Trump should campaign on
pardoning the January 6 defendants
I mean I I think that he should yes I'm
wondering if that would resonate
effectively with the American people
because I I feel like the people who
know for the most part like there's some
bad people who who you know were
fighting and were rioting and were
causing violence and you know they'll
get charged or you know they they should
be
penalized and charged red stuff but so
many of these people were let in the
cops opened the door they fanned them in
and now these people are getting locked
up that if Trump came out and said the
non-violent offenders from January 6
should not be charged they've paid their
their their their you know their Penance
and they should all be pardoned that
would resonate really well with people
who know what's going on but I wonder if
the general public would just be
manipulated and the corporate press
would show pictures of January 6 and
then say Trump was pardoning his
enabling yeah Terror exactly he's
pardoning terrorists because they
supported him he's a dictator and so
that's the challenge in order to win
does Trump need to
you know hold that hold that off I don't
think well that's a good point
um I'm not sure it would be a campaign
issue or a promise that he could make
one way or the other but I do think that
making what the FBI and doj has done
under the ruse of January 6th and that
is unleash this war on terror against
the American right and continuing to do
so that people are waking up because
it's not just the j6ers it's pro-lifers
now you have someone like Mark Houck
who's you know home was rated by armed
FBI agents for a pro-life Advocate
wasn't charged locally and then Merrick
Garland's doj stepped in under the face
act and and charged him with federal
crimes they've done that with multiple
pro-life activists wow charging them
with conspiracy to commit to violate
this face act which is freedom to access
um
basically abortion Services pregnancy
centers whatever you want to call it so
this is a whole new level of weaponizing
this doj and FBI against political
dissidents you know those who are
protesting the regime or have viewpoints
that are contrary to the regime and so
to see Chris Ray and Merrick Garland in
the past two days insist you know they
accept no culpability that their
agencies have been fully weaponized
against American citizens to pretend
that none of that exists they can see
what the poll they could see with polls
say they absolutely live in this
alternative uh and I mean I think Chris
Ray was belligerent the other night on
Fox News whenever Brett Baer would bring
it up and give him these examples
um and they're just in complete denial
because they can be because they don't
fear any sort of Retribution you know
the 18 Senate Republicans just gave the
doj 3.5 billion dollar raised
570 million of which went to the FBI so
what do they have to be afraid of
nothing so I do think that this is
another huge wedge issue for Trump
um and I think things are only going to
get worse and as the tapes come out as
people see the other side of what
happened on January 6 as they see the
body cam footage as they push for
records you know the January 6 committee
did not interview Christopher Wray the
FBI director did not interview Stephen
dantuono who is the head of the
Washington field office you might
remember his name as the architect of
the Whitmer fednapping hoax he was
running all the Intel related to January
6 out of the Washington field office
January 6 committee never interviews him
or Christopher Wray and according to the
New York Times the FBI only turned over
2 000 records for January 6 versus the
Secret Service that turned over a
million there's a huge cover-up underway
by this FBI we're learning more about
the number of informants POS possibly up
to 15 in the proud boys which would
mirror the number who were involved in
the Whitmer remember they had like a
dozen FBI and performance undercover
agents that many people who are
allegedly involved in the kidnapping
hoax so
um we're getting a lot more material and
then all of a sudden the January 6
committee has disappeared but members of
Congress do have about 100 boxes of
materials that the January 6 committee
has kind of abandoned so they have a lot
of Records to go through a lot of
witness transcripts still have not been
released
and this has caused a real problem for
defendants who are facing very serious
charges like seditious conspiracy
Enrique tario for one who's on trial for
that in DC now because you have
potentially exculpatory evidence in
these videos and in the records that
were turned over produced by the January
6 committee so this is not over by a
long shot and I know that there are
Republicans in Washington who are very
serious about looking at all of this
including the wet Whitmer fudnabbing
hoax but but it just seems like the only
way anything will change is if
Republicans win everything like that's
right so so these next couple of years
it's going to be hurry up and wait
vlogging through Tina's and records and
letters and public testimony like we saw
Merit Garland today but they don't have
the power of the doj you know to execute
criminal referrals so yeah it will be
two years away before anything major can
happen it's very frustrating especially
for the defendants especially for people
in solitary confinement that's right
that's like the process is the
punishment and then they'll be like okay
fine after all said and done five years
later they can all go free we did it
you know probably shouldn't say this but
we're planning on being in Congress
Friday for another show at the Capitol
and uh yes the idea of being floated is
to get some Squad members maybe some
Democrats and I'm just like you can
invite a mom but I'm not going to go
easy you know like AOC fabricated that
story about January 6. that's serious
stuff she was murdered a few times but
she and and that story she told she made
it up yes she did but I'll be on her
side on that just the in in that when
you're when you're in a situation where
you feel like you're under a lot of
pressure your memory goes hey what can
go Haywire
that's right Ian literally right after
the event she forgot what happened that
day
all of the times that AOC was murdered
every single one hope this is a great
idea you know if we're going to heal
this country that's how we do it you
know what though if you do have a chance
to interview any of them you should ask
them about this dual system of justice
and where have they been not speaking
out you know these are the criminal
justice reformers you know no cash bail
and people shouldn't be held you know
denied bail Etc and they've been
completely silent it would be great to
confront them and say don't you think
that these people are due the same due
process rights presumption of innocence
Etc that you ask for for actual
criminals not people who walked into a
public building on Wednesday afternoon I
completely agree with you and I I also
want to take one second to point to the
one of the opening arguments or one of
the opening remarks I forget who who
made it but he pointed out that the FBI
has gone from being a law enforcement
agency to an intelligence agency
essentially and the United States is not
supposed to have a domestic intelligence
agency the CIA is supposed to be
prohibited from operating here in the
U.S the Nia is suppose the dni and stuff
they're supposed to be prevented from
operating in the United States and the
FBI is also not supposed to be uh an
intelligence gathering outfit it's
supposed to be a law enforcement outfit
I put a poll up right now
asking should I go light on AOC if it
means you come on the show and what I
mean let me clarify
if I was actually going to sit down and
interview AOC I would I would go pretty
heavy I'd question the green New Deal I
would explain how she had my support in
the before she wrote it up because I
care about infrastructure but this bill
was critical race Theory I would
question her on the fabrication of that
story that she claimed they knocked in
the door where is she where is she oh my
God they made it here except that story
took place an hour before anyone
breached the capital maybe she has a
real answer for it but there's a
potential in the negotiations in getting
her on the show I'm not saying she wants
to come on the show I'm not saying she's
ever been asked I'm saying I've got
people in the capital saying we would
like to extend an invite to them
if they come back to me and say Squad
members have agreed to come on the show
but these topics are off limits you can
talk policy you can talk establishment
and current events but no one wants to
talk about their personal you know
issues or whatever should I say yes to
that no so then we just don't have them
on the show no definitely not if people
aren't willing to talk about things then
they shouldn't come on you say yes and
then you ask them whatever the hell you
want and then you get when they get up
and storm out like Kanye you just you
throw your hands up in the air as a
victory that's dishonorable you think so
absolutely if it look if if I have a
leftist come to me and they say I'm
gonna tell you stuff it's off the Record
and they tell me some pretty bad stuff I
keep it off the Record if someone says I
will come and sit with you and talk
about policy I'll talk about January 6th
I'll talk about the vote for McCarthy
I'll talk about the current bills in
Congress I will not talk about my
involvement or my story like if you said
I won't talk to you about my story on
Instagram and if you bring it up I'm out
then I would say then we won't talk
about it
I don't think so if it was private
information that no one knew definitely
we do not talk about that stuff but it's
it's public data it's you know it's Up
For Debate it's up for discussion I
think it's probably worth getting them
on the show I think I think
agreeing to certain things that they
don't want to discuss is if you if you
say it beforehand I mean I in my opinion
you should if that were to happen you
should make it known to the audience
these are the things that they won't
talk about so I can't I'm not going to
ask them and then go into it with the
audience knowing because then the
audience knows what the politician said
no I don't talk about we we have people
who say they'll come on the show but
they don't want to talk about something
so it's like this happens all the time
people like I really don't want to talk
about religion and then I'll be like
okay like you know we won't right
however that's not a specific thing
right so in the issue of AOC you know so
when I get asked like hey should we like
the people in Capitol Building know her
people they'll ask her and I'm like
there's no way she'll do it because the
first thing I'm going to do is be like
yo that story on January 6 you that you
made that up that's not a real story
like and that's serious stuff like like
maybe she's got an explanation maybe she
can explain it away but couldn't you
just say we want to talk about January
6th and just not bring that out but you
think they'll come back and say she will
except she doesn't want to talk about
the time she was murdered right okay
what will likely happen is they'll just
say no and the reason they'll say no is
because they know I'm gonna say hey
remember that story you told on
Instagram for 45 minutes where you
claimed people knocked on your door and
you thought they were coming to kill you
but that happened an hour before the
building had been breached did you know
the building was going to be breached
and if not why did you fabricate a story
claiming you thought people were coming
to kill you when you couldn't have known
the building was going to be breached I
guess the other answer is she knew in
advance before anyone else including
security that they were going to bridge
the building that's why she was scared
or the reality is she made up a story
for the internet to get to get clicks
and likes
we're going to go to super chats but I'm
gonna do something else first I'm gonna
play this video for you because it's
awesome I saw this retweeted I can't
remember who tweeted it it's uh
socialism is a philosophy of failure the
Creed of ignorance and the gospel of
Envy its inherent virtue is the equal
sharing of misery Sir Winston Churchill
and this is Rebecca Paul in Surrey
telling a story two minutes long and
you're gonna love it let's play it
oh can you set the audio
here we go you guys ready
let me tell you a scary story is it good
an economics professor at a local
College made a statement that she had
never failed a single student before but
had recently failed an entire class the
class had insisted that socialism worked
that no one would be poor and no one
would be rich a great equalizer
the professor then said okay we will
have an experiment in this class all
grades will be averaged and everyone
will receive the same grade no one will
fail but no one will receive an a either
after the first test the grades were
averaged and everyone got a B the
students who studied hard were upset and
the students who studied little were
happy
as the second test rolled around the
students who studied little studied even
less and the ones who studied hard
decided they wanted a free ride too so
they studied little the second average
test result was a d no one was happy
when the third test rolled around the
average was an F as the test proceeded
the scores never improved
bickering name-calling and blame all
resulted in hard feelings
would study for the benefit of anyone
else to their great surprise all failed
and the professor told them that
socialism would ultimately fail because
when the reward is great the effort to
succeed is great when the government
takes away all the reward no one will
try or want to succeed
and that is socialism my friends a race
to the bottom
that was great it was a really great
video probably never happened but if I
was a teacher I would totally do that if
I was like a college and had a bunch of
Lefty socialist kids I'd be like all
right we're going to average all your
grades out and then I'm going to put it
they will here's the thing I bet if you
told that to some socialist they would
be like no no no no no no no no don't do
that because then it's like you're gonna
have this forever and your your college
transcripts or whatever that you failed
it's all you baby
someone in chat just noticed uh or just
mentioned a song that I wrote about
socialism so cheers to that oh yeah what
was that this song's called Wasteland
we're gonna go to super chats if you
haven't already would you kindly smash
that like button subscribe to this
channel share the share with your
friends and become a member over at
timcast.com we're gonna have a members
only live show coming up
goes up around excuse me 10 10 p.m we
are just trying out there's no Discord
yet we are working on a live chat system
but I guess we're not going to Discord
because everyone's saying we'll get
banned anyway so okay
then uh then we won't we will um we will
find some other system but let's read
some super chats we got I'm not your
buddy guy he says look up the story on
the Maricopa County election oversight
committee with Jacqueline Berger reveals
the Sinaloa cartel being low cartel
being involved in bribing officials
laundering their drug and trafficking
money through fake real estate purchases
and fake identities these fake
identities were then used to manipulate
the election results in reelecting those
who are not in on the money laundering
including their staff which has total I
think more than 18 billion dollars it
was always about the money we should
have seen it from the start that being
said I'm not your buddy guy mentions
from Gateway pundit but I do not find
the Gateway pundit to be credible at all
they falsely claimed that George Soros
endorsed Rhonda sandis which he didn't
and that kind of fake news really pisses
me off so take it out with a grain of
salt I suppose
all right Raymond g Stanley Jr says Tim
zielinski can shut his dumb mouth ain't
no way the American people will be okay
with sending our kids to die in some bs4
in war protest of the 60s 60s will have
nothing on protesters tomorrow perhaps
I'm not sure I'm not so sure I agree
what do you guys think I think there
will be a lot more armed protesters if
that was to come to uh ahead in the in
the present in the 60s you saw a lot of
people standing out there without guns
this time there would be guns yeah I
mean bombs were mailed in the 60s and
70s and bought like bought male male
bombs were were happening very
frequently in the United States it was I
don't want to say a normal thing but
like it was not a peaceful time and even
with the George Floyd riots in 2020 the
the new cultural revolution if you want
to call it that here in the U.S is still
not as violent as the late 60s and and
early 70s were we just got up our
cameras now yeah you just you can see it
a lot more but there were a lot of
people that were mailing a lot of bombs
and a lot of those people are no longer
in jail and they're in they're teaching
in schools yikes all right cubicle
investor says Tim and Ian did you see
that magic the Gathering is releasing a
Lord of the Rings set they race swapped
Aragorn to be more inclusive and people
are complaining that it ruins the lore
thoughts
yeah I have a lot of them uh no I don't
think I've seen that Lord of the Rings
um I I kind of am of the opinion I don't
care what skin color fantasy characters
have I never really have unless it has
something to do with this character
specifically like he's the a slave from
1820 in the United States with Children
of slave and then they make him like a
white guy or an Asian guy be like well
what's you know if he was like this is a
black slave from the 1820s and then they
make him a white guy I'll be like I'm
confused now but essentially I don't
care I don't care who fake Aragorn is
really I hope the the set's not too
busted I'm trying to load the images but
they're not loading
Aragorn is the uh the ranger guy right
yeah yeah he's the king the Return of
the King yes spoiler alert if you
haven't seen that oh wow yeah he's just
straight around the black dude
yeah here oh nice it's like not even
swarthy like it just literally outright
Aragorn is just outright black but they
should have maybe they probably didn't
have the money to get uh what's his name
the faces it's just so weird that like
someone sat down and said all right
let's do Aragorn a guy goes making black
and they're like you got it it's Hasbro
dude this company owns DND and Magic now
it's this multinational corporation who
owns Hasbro somebody owns Hasbro well
good for them I guess Greg Cutler says
please have Ben Davidson from suspicious
observers on your show he said he'd love
to if invited we'll uh we'll take a look
we will take a look Steven say he says
when the balloon pass over my house Tick
Tock was loaded on my phone against my
will no one has addressed this strange
strange have you guys talked about the
government Banning Tick-Tock did you
talk about that last night they're
getting ready to ban it right yeah
they're preparing to ban it from all
government devices in the next 30 days
good yeah there's nothing wrong with
that at all people think that like if I
understand correctly they're they're
talking about banning from government
devices they're not prohibiting uh
government employees from having their
own device that has tick tock on it and
it's not like they're telling people
they can't bring their own phone to work
at a government installation
I think it's fine it's probably better
not right if it's on your phone because
I don't I'm I'm banned from it and and
that's that's not fair so we should just
the country should ban it Donald Trump
should go in an executive order ban it
get him well I do think they should uh
ban it because it is Chinese
manipulation it's fifth generational
Warfare and you're getting a bunch of
weird I mean there's a Libs of tic tac
account for a reason
not in China true Mao dib says we should
write in Ukraine as a dependent on our
taxes
nice haha that's a good point
all right what do we got waffle Sensei
says well at least we can rest assured
that Biden didn't give Putin a list of
all our most critical infrastructure am
I right
yeah oh yeah what targets not to attack
here are the things that are off limits
you know don't blow these things up and
he's like are you serious in the hip and
Nordstrom like what yeah
all right
I am says we have forever Wars because
narcissists can't contribute to the
economy so we made an artificial one
that never ends unfortunately requires
loss of life to achieve their goal
that's what I'm talking about these
these whiny hipster liberal types who
don't have to work because we have guns
and bombs and I'm just like you know I'm
I'd be happier if our economy wasn't as
strong as it was now I should say this
the economy should be strong but it's
weirdly falsely inflated right now you
should work a heart you should work hard
but make enough to have a family to buy
a house to to to save for your families
your kids future and things like that
but now what we have is hard-working
people working in factories making 20
bucks an hour and fat body positive
influencers getting paid millions of
dollars to eat Ben Jerry's every night
like something's wrong with that you
know what I mean
all right the the KL tanker says I've
been wondering why instead of making
laws that citizens laws that citizens
Sue to see if they are constitutional
why not have a ruling on
constitutionally constitutionality
before apply and three strikes to the
members who uh propose unconstitutional
bills that's a good idea the idea should
be that after Congress passes a law the
it should go to the Supreme Court
immediately who should then weigh in the
constitutionality of it and if they do
it can get signed into effect by the
executive well yeah we should do that
that's that should be what the Supreme
Court does is that do they just keep the
judicial system separate for uh
separation of power yep yeah but it's
like they pass a law and then you have
to sue the government to challenge it
and then it goes to the court so like
the government is allowed to do unjust
things until you you convince them
they're not I would run that by a
constitutional lawyer but on its face
that actually does sound like a good
idea I haven't put a whole lot of
thought into it to find the holes or
whatever but that seems reasonable to me
hillbillary Clinton says flag behind
Phyllis crooked might as well turn it
upside down instead of fixing it though
because our country is for sure in
distress it's not crooked it's not yeah
I answered earlier it's not crooked it
just looks crooked from the angle of the
cameras guys is that what it is yeah
because you can if you look at the trim
on the wall you can see it's perfectly
the Tim cast behind Julius is crooked
yeah but it looks straight it looks oh
does it yeah it does because no because
the nails busted on it yeah it looks
straight I mean I guess like I can
adjust to make it crooked and then make
it look straight to you guys we'll see
yeah well you know
amenphe says if a draft over Ukraine is
ever entertained I can see Nationwide
rage and non-compliance but the left
will still not learn a single lesson
agreed
yeah after they volunteer and go get
their legs blown out blown off they will
full KIRO Alex Jones says Glenn Beck
interviewed Trump about Ukraine this
week and when asked what he would do he
said we are close to World War III but
he loves zelenski because of Ukraine
gate Trump's ego can be used to extend
this war
I don't know I didn't see that would we
have is DeSantis going to end the war
or cut off you know our funding of it I
think zelinski like objectively is has
been a fantastic War leader if you think
he didn't flee he had the opportunity to
run away right in the beginning and give
it up and he chose to stay and I think
that was his choice I mean obviously he
had the backing of NATO we that we
didn't know publicly but you know he's
doing his charismatic Duty so I'm not
too hard on people that say he's doing a
good job for who he is and where he is I
just don't like where he is I don't like
that the situation
meatball motivates Us in the event of
nuclear war All That Remains is
filibondi and as I as I Lay Dying I hear
him say kill switch engage in a
disturbed voice as America though in
Flames is Avenged Sevenfold wow is All
That Remains was that like a nihilistic
thing about the end of the liberal
economic order when you were creating it
no no back then it was I really put the
only thought that I put into it was this
sounds cool and I don't think there's
another band with that name that was it
like all the all the cool one name one
word names were taken up you know
Slayers are gone yes
all right what do we got pzf says today
a 16 year old student was stabbed to
death at a high school in my town I live
in California it's getting really ugly
out there out here yeah it certainly is
and that's why I think a lot of these
woke DA's are going to get booted out
yeah like we're seeing Lori Lightfoot
people are not happy with the crime man
all right Cody Justin Fannin says it's
funny how the left stands against Nazis
when they want to send money to Ukraine
ha ha or they'd stand with them I guess
that one's funny
I just want to point out and chat blob
monster I think gave me about 10 ones
which actually means he gave me a 10. so
keep them coming buddy ten ones I think
so all right Christopher Hunter says
everyone should tweet their governor and
ask if the federal government gives
orders to your State's national guard to
go fight in a frivolous war will they uh
will they order the National Guard to
defy Federal orders and stay home
interesting question
it only matters in election season
though so there might be like elections
not for two years shut up and then good
luck
what do we got here
Sakura says happy first day of women's
History Month I tell you what it's about
but I'm not a biologist
uh March is women's History Month yeah
whatever that is what I just since
that deeply offends me because my
birthday's in March oh yeah true
wouldn't you call it herstery month
though guys yeah come on her story Miss
missed opportunity there it's about
great women through history they talk a
lot about the founding fathers I think
the founding mothers don't get enough
attention
Martha Washington others like uh oh uh
Adams John Adams
Betsy Ross man
she sewed the flag her flag is now
considered a icon of domestic terrorism
bulletin list I literally have the Betsy
Ross flag
you better be careful where you wear it
well I can't take the arm off
screw up
anyway Nixon claimed the plan was to
invade China after conquering Vietnam
maybe the government is still thinking
about it I really doubt it man we don't
have the resources for a ground Invasion
it always in China why were they in
Vietnam I don't think it was just to
stop communist it must have been oil
maybe the invasion of China I don't know
stop coming the communism I mean that's
why we're still in Korea yeah it was to
stop that's why what they said they said
it was about our freedom in the Middle
East too it was never about the freedom
it was it was resources it was about
stopping communism and there's a lot of
Malaysian oil the trans-pacific
partnership was trying to get us to the
investors State dispute settlement
clause in that was trying to get us to
become able to be sued by Malaysian oil
companies so the Soviet Union had been
absorbing countries for decades after
the end of the cold or at the after the
end of the the second world war and the
United States truly believed that the
the it was called the domino theory that
countries were going to fall one by one
to Communism and it like there was a lot
of the wars that really were about
stopping communism because communism is
a global ideology right so that for to
have true communism you have to have
Global communism that's why when you
talk to Communists they'll continuously
say real communism has never been tried
there have been socialist countries but
we haven't had communism because we
don't have communism until it's Global
so that's that's part of the ideology of
Communism and that is what the United
States was actually fighting against
today the ideology is expansive and they
were literally taking country after
country that's what the that's what the
Cold War was about was preventing the
global takeover
says hey Tim Matt brainerd's
organization Lookout America got banned
from Discord they moved over to gilded
so we'll take a look at gilded yeah and
we won't support uh discordant yeah it's
on the listio can is it the same thing
basically or what for what I understand
uh I've heard about it before yeah we'll
look into it
Lord Joseph Cole says please fix the
flag behind Phil it is crooked and
driving me nuts it's literally not
crooked I don't know what to tell you
man it's not I'm gonna do the show like
this I don't know I'm looking at it and
I'm like
I mean maybe uh it's tilted to the left
like like to the left five degrees or
something I mean counterclockwise no now
it's very good now it'll be more crooked
not still wait wait you might have to
tell her down I think that's right
I feel like now it's crooked yeah for
sure
you got to pull it down a little bit
right that's right that's right right
keep going a little more a little bit
more
that's looking good oh yeah right
there's good yeah boom okay it's fixed
leave me alone that's where it was the
grains on the walls are not horizontally
straight if you're not closely yeah
right well yeah but the bottom of the
trim is and I'm like I'm looking at the
flag it's like I think it's the camera
angle makes the flag look like it's not
straight or something yes
you know
all right where are we at where we got
some uh it's gonna make a really
off-color joke about
gender ideology all right not being
straight
Stevie Vivi says why is there a green
velociraptor in the village south of
little village on the map are they
saying that the ward map of Chicago
looks like it has a little dinosaur on
it I think Godzilla is attacking Chicago
well how about that
this just in
Ginger Mac Isaac says the correct answer
to two all census surveys is human I
have answered like this for years
checked into a doctor's office that's
what race I was I told her human she
then asked if uh so if you were filling
out the census other human
yeah
what race are you human race okay
I'm the 50 meter
yeah the yes that's right David a says
the left in a nutshell nine dishonorable
Romulan destroyers attacked one
honorable Klingon battleships who had
more Firepower
whoever shot first
we've got a really really great Star
Trek bit in the next cast castle that I
can't say because it'll ruin the joke
but it's so funny
it's actually really funny uh I'll just
put it this way
we're going to be using a whole lot of
deep fakes
we can basically have anybody we want in
our shows now so good and we are going
to have them all that's right it's gonna
be very fun and uh you know I don't know
we'll see what happens
all right what do we got here Raymond
just Stanley June says Tim dude the way
you talk about the the jab issues lately
is and how you tweet super sarcastic
undertones If I Didn't Know Better
no poke good
we'll see man I don't know I'm not a
doctor I ain't no doctor but I can tell
you this the conspiracy theorists have
been literally right about everything
there's a funny you know the meme of the
guy spraying champagne in himself but
he's in like eighth place yeah so it's
that Meme but he's in first place and it
says conspiracy theorists and he's
number one and he's like what are you
saying
conspiracy 100 but the funny thing is
it's like they're not conspiracy
theorists it's like a regular person
says oh that's strange I wonder if that
virus came out of that lab and they were
like you're a conspiracy Yeah by using
the term conspiracy theorists they lump
it in with people that think the Earth
is flat yeah yeah exactly it's like oh I
wonder if it came out of that lab racist
really yeah like what Joe spinella says
my grandfather is from the south side of
Chicago back when they had two
professional football teams and he's an
FDR Democrat but he would tell me during
elections he would play both sides and
get paid putting up and tearing down
campaign posters hmm
crazy
where are we at objective 704 says
update on the V tuber that was bullied
by trans activists she's quitting she's
a sweet half Japanese girl living in
Japan No Quarters for Trans activists
long live the kettle that's a really sad
story these people are really really
mean and uh basically harassed this uh
this woman into quitting her job so you
know figuratively No Quarter these
people should be condemned for being
such nasty awful people and causing harm
for playing video game right playing
Harry Potter yeah which is like one of
the most popular games right now I made
like a billion dollars right everybody's
playing it I'm playing it you know I'm
in Slytherin by the way but it's really
dumb because you basically choose which
which house you want to be in and so the
other thing too is you your character
can be any gender you can make a male
character and then give it a female
voice or a female kick to the male voice
and you can put in whatever dorm you
want and so like they're calling the
game transphobic and I'm like you can
literally make like a petite five foot
dainty feminine woman with a deep voice
and then put her in the men's dorm room
and like the game lets you do all of
this it's so weird as soon as you could
like customize avatars in video games
all of my friends made the most
ridiculous clown looking characters like
you like in in San Andreas you could
make that you can put the clown hair on
him they always looked as ridiculous as
possible you know and and now it's it's
like people want to do that in real life
how do you make your guys I always make
my guys look like me for the most part I
make them look ridiculous unless it
takes too long well no the default the
new GTA it's going to be a lady who's
committing all these crimes yeah so yeah
can she get fat probably it would be
hilarious if she was like if you could
get a jacket you can like you can in all
of them because you can get jet you
could lift weights and get jacked in San
Andreas so I'm awesome if you could just
like go like keep going to like the
pizza place and continuously gain weight
all right that's slower here we go
that'd be awesome
certain cars you can't get into David
David Toronto says Trump isn't Biden he
can actually produce coherent thoughts
on his own ha ha repeat cheap says
apparently Lori lightfootfoot blames her
loss on those
yeah uh she does look like Gollum we
could maybe do a bit with the gollum
voice Andy Circus for uh what's her name
Jacinda is it the lady from New Zealand
Arden that progression photo she's
turning into Gollum
man that's so good chuckson Robert says
there's Starlet from us
I love that it's a really really good
guy so good man yeah we should uh we
should make fun of people and call them
Gollum more often all right where are we
at James Madison's Ghost says when
kovitz started China when Kobe started
China welded people into their homes
it's scary Trump asked fauci and the
establishment what to do and they said
lockdowns and vacs ASAP Trump did that
wrong move but he acted in a populist
manner
you know when they first started they
just flew a bunch of people out of the
country they tried to spread it I don't
know it looked like they were totally
cool keeping it open they call it
coveted 19 because it was in 2019 that
it started so people are saying I did a
really good Lori lifehood impression
yeah that the gollum was spot dude the
Lori lifehood impression yeah your lower
Lightfoot is number one yeah my lawyer
my Lori Lightfoot so I can do my Nancy
Pelosi
and uh maybe I just need Sheamus's help
to have Lori Lightfoot Nancy Pelosi
debate
oh and after that's your Pelosi talking
to Lori Lightfoot
that's how she sounds
I mean I intentionally make it sound
awful but you know I enjoy it
all right uh jashabbeam says hast thou
as spied the malevolent buffoonery
Ubisoft hath commenced wherein hate
speech is reported to the constabulous
constabulary in Europe me thinks
Insanity as such spreads only from
complete lunacy
this is like the voice chat when you're
playing an Ubisoft game is being
recorded and sent to British police is
that what you're saying is that what
they're doing I don't know I think I've
heard this that they're monitoring voice
chat is the British police I don't know
are you talking about the UK yeah I
think so zoa Noah Zork says talk about
Trump's aggressive weird tick tocks what
is that is Trump on Tick Tock or
something
I have not seen him on Tick Tock no idea
Daniel Kalinowski says the irony of
saying trumped up charges with all the
false allegations raised during 45's
Reign I know it's like a a reverse slang
term like you know right normally if you
know Trump did something you'd say
pulling a Trump would be you know like
pulling an e in or something it's like a
thing related to what Ian would do but
now it's actually in verse trumped up
charges have always been the the idiom
and now that Trump is facing trumped-up
charges it's like retroactively applying
his name to the phrase what do you say
about a trump card now like what's
what's a trump card is it still a trump
card to pull a trump card is that like
I don't know yeah yeah
it's something that uh a leftist would
be upset about yeah I don't know he has
to cancelable term I assume yeah
Constantine Thomas says my fiance wants
fiance wants to make you guys a free
flag for your set
KRW Creations let her know what you
would like I don't know big chicken or
something be cool actually Roberto Jr
we have that uh stand your ground flag
it's uh Roberto Jr holding up his wings
you know because roosters will sacrifice
themselves to save the hens
we have it's downstairs no oh yeah yeah
we sell it we sell it on our website you
can get it so it's kind of like the
Gadsden flag but it's like yellow and
it's got the rooster
it's important for everybody who doesn't
know but if there's a bunch of chickens
and they're like grazing and like a fox
is coming up the rooster will charge the
fox knowing it will die to give the hens
a chance to escape you've been around
chickens to know that I have known this
for a long time the noble rooster and
it's I'm telling you like
to call someone a chicken is is
inappropriate seeing that a chicken
knows anything is is a stretch of what
the me the word knowing means I mean the
reason that the animals run away from
predators because they know they'll die
so when the rooster chooses to run
towards it it like I'm gonna die but I'm
gonna try and let the hens Escape so we
have a video of Roberto back when he was
there when he was now it's Roberto Jr
his son Roberto's off at cocktown and uh
uh a hawk or something swooped down and
Roberto ran and then waited outside the
coop for the girls to go in before he
went in yeah man and so roosters the
noble chicken has more honor and and
bravery than most people in this country
come on yeah can't even be as Brave as a
rooster chicken's an understatement jeez
but there's a lot of people in this
country who are like the noble rooster
you know willing to run into burning
buildings and brave the line of fire to
save people uh fighting Wars whether you
know we trust the government or not
they're trying to do the right thing for
their for their community and for their
their country so you know some Americans
are like roosters yes you know but not
enough of them not enough
Laura hen says dropped out of college to
go on my own as a t-shirt salesman
trying to change culture with cool stuff
that isn't the Boomer weird text shirts
would love to send y'all some my Etsy is
revolutionary people cool someone want
to write that down do it yeah we
actually have a P.O box I think it's
still active you want to write it down
too
Raymond g Stanley Jr says Tim I'll
donate to a leftist cause for AOC on IRL
like if the idea was we would come on
and talk about current news and not past
culture War issues pertaining to each
other fine right like is that yeah if we
got past the crap she'd be one of the
best guests of all time we just
constantly have her want to be so
awesome I don't know about that because
we disagree that's part of the or like I
don't even know if I disagree I just
want to find out but we need like Stark
opposing voices to triangular well we've
got uh we got some liberals coming on
real soon actually who I'm not I gotta
want to announce it because they
canceled sorry if you if you if when you
so one of the there's two reasons we
don't announce announce guests one is
they cancel abruptly for any reason and
then we have to say sorry guys it's not
happening and cancellations happen all
the time right someone will be like hey
like especially if someone's from like
in Congress they're going to be like hey
we're gonna we've had it several times
we're gonna come on this date they book
it and then like two days before they're
like they're doing a vote we're not
gonna be able to make it we're gonna be
stuck so sorry have a nice day and if we
announce it you know but the other
reason is some of these guests will
start getting attacked and so then
they'll just panic and then you know
yeah they'll be like I don't wanna oh no
I'm scared
the Red Rum access bring AOC and Alex
Stein together you see no here's the
thing
there's got to be a good faith effort to
have a sit-down conversation that's kind
of my point right once we become friends
then we can have Alex and Alex and it'll
be like oh my God we're more human than
we realize I don't I don't I don't see
it I don't see that happening I do and
I'm a Visionary really we can do
anything the reality is Malia I just
I'll put it this way I don't think
there's any agreement that would result
in someone like AOC coming on this show
I just they're gonna the people will go
to her and say hey would you want to
come on there's going to be these people
and you're welcome to come too I think
so and they're and their staff is going
to say do not do it it's the green new
deal because if we really do start
pulling carbon out of the air and making
graphene with it and create an
industrial revolution that's something I
think we can all use as a ground swell
yeah Oh you mean nope the green Leap
Forward
like the green Leap Forward that's good
I mean if we're gonna put government
funds in we shouldn't we should we
should make that shirt yeah that'd be
greatly I'd wear that every day I would
wear that yep what would it say though
like oppose the green Leap Forward or
something uh no it would be in favor of
it yeah it has to be like some a bunch
of cool people you don't like we got to
put AOC in the Chinese Communists or
like Soviet outfit or whatever Chinese
Communist like looking like Mao yeah
yeah definitely and then it would be
like the green Leap Forward you know I'm
all for it that'd be great it'd be great
I will wear one
let's grab some more super jets
DD Mega doodoo says you should just put
Sheamus's Mexican flag up behind Phil
his holiday is coming up
for you mean wait Sheamus is Irish flag
it's funny because Sheamus is from
Chicago but he like puts an Irish flag
up I'm like Sheamus I know you're Irish
like people can hear your name but
you're from the United States
yeah well you know I just I just did
some lines for for Sheamus I sound like
cocaine there for a second bro what I
just did some lines
yeah bring me back Cristiano says Tim's
beanie is crooked fix it please
no it's actually pretty good it's
actually pretty all right
it's actually it's actually doing good
all right like what do we got here
Henry Vale says got membership to say
this y'all should read the prologue of
Hugh Benson's lord of the World book
greatly describes the 1900s and Marxist
social progression has a lot to say
about the modern crisis
that video of that woman explaining the
classroom was really really great I
doubt that really happened that story
but it really does explain exactly why
socialism fails because you are outright
telling people you will not be rewarded
for hard work they say okay then why
would I do it it is not possible to make
the uncapable capable so you must make
the capable incapable you cannot take
people that don't have the ability to do
things like and and make them able to do
things so you only way you can make
Equity happen in reality or make Equity
manifest in reality is to take away from
people that can take away their property
take their abilities take away their
their Liberty to do things and act in
the world Lori lemon in the member chat
said Phil's headphones are lopsided
please fix I'm kidding I think they're
trolling I I added the police picks that
was me
all right Tyler Henry says I'm a septic
technician and I can't stop thinking
about your talk yesterday with liberals
moving out of cities I show up to
people's houses with fancy cars and
Biden stickers and not wanting to learn
how to avoid the problems this is the
crazy thing like when you do it when you
handle septic right you don't got to do
anything for for a really really really
long time and depending on the size of
it depending on the size of your family
the people use it but we're in a
building that's not a septic system it's
a very large system but we also have a
lot of people here we have a lot of
guests and it's really really
frustrating because everybody who comes
here comes from cities you know almost
most of the guests come here they live
in cities and they don't know you
literally can't use it you can't flush
anything down this so we have to have
the company come out and and deal with
it all the time but you know it is what
it is it is what it is
all right we'll grab one more
bar fighting says who's going chicken
hunting you know whis going chicken
hunting get paid my man
is that a is that a ICP reference I have
no idea is that Insane Clown Posse
let me just uh
is it is that what it is
yes that was right chicken hunting is a
song by Insane Clown Posse see because I
just remember these things don't ask me
why my friends if you haven't already
would you kindly smash that like button
subscribe to this Channel and share the
show with your friends if you really do
like it because you know we've done
marketing as kind of a statement with
the Times Square stuff but they're
really marketing these days the only
effective marketing is people who like
the show telling other people about
that's it they always say like for
podcasts the best way for a podcast to
grow is that it's just good and so if we
are good and you share with your friends
then that's good for us and if we're not
good and you don't share it well then so
be it that's what we deserve so uh smash
that like button subscribe to the
channel become a member at timcast.com
we're going to set up that members only
live stream it'll go live in about 10
minutes and uh not family friendly we
had a lot more to talk about pertaining
to Trump and things like that should be
a lot of fun you can follow the show at
timcast IRL you can follow me personally
at timcast Julie do you want to shout
anything out
um no thank you for having me you can
catch me on Twitter can I give my
Twitter handle yes of course because I
Do cover a lot of stuff on January 6th
videos and court filings that are
interesting they really are interesting
though Julie underscore Kelly too and
all my work said American greatness and
greatness.com that's where people get
your book
uh they can get my book on Amazon the
name of the book again is oh man January
6th how Democrats use the capital
protest to launch a war on terror
against the political right
yeah thanks
I am Phil Labonte I am Phil that remains
on Twitter Phil that remains official on
Instagram
and uh yeah give me a follow yeah you
guys I've heard some people wanted to
send stuff to uh timcast you can by
timcast.com contact is where you can
find the PO box and here it is PO Box
1229 Frederick Maryland 21702 if you
want it but again it's on timcast.com
contact so you can get it there send us
whatever you need to send us I know I
think Serge you mentioned you're going
to follow up as well and uh catch you
guys later yeah I wrote down the people
who commented uh with I think I forget
what they are now but I wrote them down
on this uh what they call these what do
we call these sticky notes sticky notes
that's the word uh anyways I am at
search.com
um thank you for joining us Julie I
appreciate it it was fun thanks for
having me and uh of course we as we're
expanding the new facility I guess we
need a like General handyman somebody
who knows how to use appliances
equipment Like Water Systems septic
things like that because somebody's
Super Chat together day that if we
needed a plumber and I was like actually
we might need someone like that and then
I was talking about it today with upper
management and they were like we we need
like a general maintenance handyman who
can maintain everything because now
we've got the new studio being built
which is going to be like three
buildings yeah so we definitely need
someone because if something we've had
like leaks before because of the AC and
then we're like ah what do we do and
then it's like Sunday and we call and
there's nobody and we can't yeah so you
got three buildings you need at least
one maintenance person exactly exactly
so please manager that being said um I
don't know I think it's jobs at
timcast.com or something like that is
the email okay there you go all right
everybody we'll see you all over at
timcast.com thanks for hanging out